salut femme est entrée à faire des trucs
les espagnols but mexicain et brésilien
tout le monde soit fait français ouais
je suis entraîné je me suis échauffé
quoi je te l'avoué je sais bien ce soir
je vais en faire un pendant les parties
quand y'en a marre si un but là bas je
suis moi je suis pour anish giri un
perso je serais pour mam et du coude
pour qui veut situer du côté des
perdants fais ce que tu veux quoi
non mais cet amant autant que j'en parle
de guy rivage et en reparler monfils qui
rejoue mais c'est un moment que j'en dis
beaucoup de biens non que tu as il faut
que j'aie un certain et c'est parti du
bio il commença alors quoi ils sont
chauds quoi mater des cats quoi donc wap
et stream pédagogique que je prends le
sens thann et si ce n'est pas de couper
la belgique est bon même à mais je pense
qu'il prend ce match un peu par dessus
la jambe yeux à une jambe et le match et
par deux superbes voilà mais bon on
gagnera alors quand m un objectif qu'il
faut quand même dire que pour le
vainqueur en finale à cannes 10000
dollars de prix en finale non mais je
tourne la rend un non serait quand même
très heureux de raser dix mille ha bah
oui nous en fait enfin vous pourrez
comme des morts de faim accord va en
fout on serait là un match mais s'il
savait tonton une heure dans votre
compagne avant de filer au club je sais
pas si t'as pas plus intérêts qu'elle
m'a regardé le match en fait tu vas
faire au club mais non désastreux que tu
passes un même nom mais honnêtement je
préfère discuter avec un de mes élèves
quoi tu vas je disais quelque part plus
intéressant de voir l'élite mondiale que
d'aller tu vois je les lis de la nation
quoi pas du coup je te ferais bien un
ticket value 2 qui a voyagé 3 et balancé
l'option achat déjà non mais bon j'ai
pas je veux bien les noires blanches
vous côté joueurs de pierre etaix fleur
de pierre qui comme vous l'avez battu à
boom sur h4 mais il a dit je te dis
qu'en métier dans l'esprit c'est une
fausse réputation qu'il a
michaud quoi hockey mom oussama serait
un c'est bon on s'en fiche qu'est ce
qu'on fait
il n'a pas en plus dans l'esprit que toi
sale avant wim ok admettons mais ok est
ce que tu es 17 de jeu ont fait perdre 0
5 3 mais on repart pas où je reprendrai
d'être devant je sais pas je remets de
cavaillon et chaque grand roc oil et
bout tu as fou on envoie une tête h5n1
- pourquoi page 5 c'est dans l'esprit
après vraiment colonnes d'un moment on
essaye dans ma vie je pense que j'ai une
mère très agressif toutes les parties
tout le temps toujours je pense qu est
ce qui se dit dans le chott manage 5
ok mais s'ils écoutent le stream en
français je suis pas sûr qu'il est ce
que j'ai une question afghane sur france
3 paris est-ce qu'il ya un moyen que le
bukut y soient toujours visibles je
retourne sur chaise comme tu fasses le
truc tu as comme plus petit et qui
mettons pas tout à droite en fait mal
foutu réduisent pour que ton papa sow
traoré option toujours par dessus je
connais pas en tout cas
non on se retrouve bien
bon du coup ce qui lui prend du fou du
cavalier en fait ce pion h5 mais ce que
je le prends ge
même si le prend pas c'est moi qui te
prend g6 ah non mais ce qu'on peut dire
qu'on peut faire ce genre d'un truc
comme ça
et quand tu prends g6 vont prendre
plutôt de f normalement je pense que tu
prends de l'âge comme s'il faisait ça 3
prendre 1 h 6 de lachute maths mais deux
bon tu tiens la photo getty s'ils
partent pas quoi mais bon pour l'instant
il est là il a pas raison d'aller voir
ailleurs
après ce petit train de vous qui
regardent la forêt la forêt mais pour
qui gambadent pas dans la forêt
tigharghar la forêt c'est une expression
russe en fait je veux s'ordonne je vous
sais très bien que les pressions je te
dise les hommes sont des loups qui
regarde l'affairé regarde sur la forêt
en fait tu comprends la métaphore est ce
que sont vraiment des arbres semblent la
question qu'on est en train de se poser
tu vas mais c'est bien c'est le jour des
des métaphores jusqu'au bout des blagues
russes n'ont jamais un truc de forêt
coiffe un fou je suis en fait mais je
veux d'idées nous comment veux tu qu'je
r'garde chauffailles visant la forêt
donc les mecs comment ils peuvent la
regarder quelque part même temps l'homme
est un loup pour l'homme
bon en fait ils regardent la forêt ok ça
veut dire c'est chic c'est plus rien
mais on va faire de la magie ses
qualités 5 ça mais c'est celui de 2007
ier froid neutre si les remet alors il a
pris d'avoir ok bon la question se pose
de rompre en vue du cavalier noir je ne
peux pas te dire pourquoi c'est le
feeling tunes mais t'as pas peur de
prendre qui prend d'un match 6 f3 et
grand roque bada match istres g8 f3 faut
aussi ses grands voici jeu pousser les
pions quoi ces choix en tout cas sympa
ce petit
posée mais c'est important que les non
récurrents b5 bien sûr pas de prendre
tous ces quatre ce serait morte à la
mamie qui s'est un peu des cadres et je
les regarderai hockey à temps il est
cavalier pour un f3 puis enfin les trois
faux prince froid je crois qu'on a pas
envie de faire d'autres on peut passer
les qualités qu'une femme ouais mais là
il veut prendre enfin louis leyrat d'âge
6 échec avant qu'est ce que ça change
est ce qui donne aux patients qu'une
cloche chez mélanie roy j'ai vite
catalogué hariri fils fait que des nues
je n'aime pas regarder ces partis mais
en fait mais c'est tellement pas vrai ce
truc tu vas combien de fois il faut voir
que j'explique en fait fab ses entrées
dans la légende fait c'est une légende
face complètement faux en fait enfin je
sais pas s'il est plus devenu que maxime
ou pas mais j'ai des remords 1915
cette année c'est sûr que non il joue en
fait main il faut assez agressif et
guéri depuis un moment mais il fait
plutôt des parties intéressantes en tout
cas c'est beaucoup insipide que je doive
s p ce brave donc soutenir hier encore
qu'il veut fermer mais ont une belle
partie face envoie des pièces de partout
où pranger les sinistres fin elle envoyé
une tournée de m
elles ont une grille il va se traîner ce
truc tout de sa vie parce qu'il a fait
une fois 14 minutes 14 secondes
mais bon et blanc mais elle a fait 9
nuls en deux fronts bas signifient la
nand aussi et personnes durera non un an
de super chiant en angleterre c'est
judith viry à 22 ans il fait ça au
candidat qu'enfin déjà afin qualifiez
vous pour les candidats déjà un ne se
fait bien longtemps qu'on n'a pas de
joueurs français aux candidats non mais
juste j'en ai marre de cet acharnement
par vraiment j'en parle souvent faibles
et tu sais que ça ça m'énerve les fausse
réputation en fait qui se traîne alors
que le mac en plus c'est plutôt faire un
ok j'ai pas envie de dire un exploit
mais ok 13 nuls en 13 parties à 22 ans
aux candidats en n'ayant raté trois
gains c'est fin tu as passé beau quoi me
je suis pas sûr que de notre vivant ou
un joueur français faire ça en fait
d'environ 6 si on peut aussi j'essaie
passe mais c'est quoi l'idée suture
griffiths bon bah faut défendre le
maintenant que je dois le faire
d'habitude cette agence et j'ai fait un
tour à 8,6 mais mesdames c'est 7
j'ai peut-être te faire f set d'un match
8,7 à pied cette fois ci sinon ça j'ai
pas envie de voir ça du coup l'action
prend un ton brandon c7000 mc c'est
peut-être tout rejet injuste c'est foutu
hockey dont gérard chute et peut-être
fief et peut-être finir encore je vais
mais je dirais ok non mes torts gérard
brach rythme fou quelques lopins fort
recul très sympa mais tour g8
s'échauffent à blain des chaussées choix
de 128 récupérer ta qualité c'est en vie
dont j'ai enrichi de fourrage cette dame
prince cette dame g7
l'impromptu reprend en bouche vous
pourrez fuite en profite mais la finale
va être plutôt mieux pour les noirs ok
moi je suis de force et je pense mais
pour l'instant j'ai pas vu de garde a
peut-être fou est huit crains j'avais
pensé à foix f16 f18 faut mixer fouinât
ce cas là c'est la forme tu as dame
trois fuites et une à ce tour g7 et
surtour g8 et à tout moment
roy prend effet cet échec est en fuite
huit matches auxquels fois eu de choix
ses lignes fluides the troll un mal fou
aux 4 ok c'est même genre d'idée mais
t'en fou prend des gens défendent
c'est sûrement - g un vrai tour j 7
quand même ouais mais très bien tourner
the way il n'y a pas de match 7 ouais
mais folie tu penses bas en a dû rater
un truc faveur
bah je suis pas sûr qu est ce qui
m'attend je n'attends comment ça marche
comment ok mais c'est juste que ça gagné
une pièce en force
j'étais chanceux bon bah du coup femmes
1 0 aller à nice
allait-on par des sifflets huit marchés
je ne joue pas alors on dit que foulée
ian ritchie guen foule dit non il va
comprendre pourquoi huit tours angers 7
tours un échec roi des deux prochains
mais il a dû voir en plus un design hors
du coup j'en reviens au direct et tous
deux un deux trois poisons
dataflux machin est emprisonné mais il
rejoint un peu ces systèmes m'a mené
avec avec le fourbe et de la moelle et
bien marché à l'audience qui devait
jouer dans les rapides franchise
tourcoing non mais c'est bien joué
madame b ici sockeye s'en prend un peu
aux foulées saint lô caïds et 4
numérique et prend des quatre foot un
point b 5 se fait au final partie
d'avant il a fini comme ans qu'on a
montré avec vos proches sont franches et
honnêtes ont fourni ou non mais c'était
super bien le flou quatre balles il
mieux que le jeu soit 8 du gooc était
spectaculaire mais qui ne fonctionnait
pas vers des ricains et leur
impressionnant surtout est gamin 10 29
88 c'est fort c'est pas mal ça approche
des 3000 quoi ok le yoga ou key 5 fu et
il peut pas prendre en d4 car il faut
prendre cet échec à la fin mais vous
êtes tellement bon dame des neiges à
défendre le chou b2 sa menace
peut-être qu'ils pensent et 6,20
sûrement d'ailleurs puisque vous
promenant drac a lieu cet échec est
occupée at il ensuite on croit d'abord
ses 8 points on porte au cap avec les
noirs qui peut quand même prendre en d4
on ramener le pion évacuées dont joue
truc symétrique qui m plus ou moins et
gagnent en moyenne je pense parce que
des fois il ya un petit avantage blanc
mais la levée de suppression
je suis assez sûr qu'ils ne l'aient pas
dire il est parti pour ça d'ailleurs
il est au mieux un traitement google
j'aurais sûrement femme qui tout comme
ça et je pense qu'il a absolument aucun
souci avec les nerfs des commentaires
c'est changer le nom des colonnes ec et
h6 fait pareil alors dit qu'on n'a pas
les scores des matchs car si on a les
scores des matchs en dessous des chics
et vous avez le nom des joueurs à les
lire et vous avez un petit 1 et un petit
0 et ça en fait c'est ça fait office de
score donc on a le score des matchs et
on allait cette fois ci face pour ce
match on a les visages de tous les
joueurs en fait pas des joueurs et de
nous en fait de nous de tout le monde
partout de tout absolument tout le monde
il ya des visages de partout quoi on vit
dans un monde de visages monde d'image
ouais ouais il n'y a pas et il n'y a pas
deux il n'y a pas de vide surtout
surtout fait remarquer de la mise en
page
ouais voulu vite quelque part ou pas
ouais je pensais quand même un même
déterminant comme argument tout est
plein ben c'est plein donc c'est gage de
qualité
c'est complètement égal en faire une
position qui est symétrique
mais on blitz ça peut se gagner pour
l'un ou pour l'autre c'est megan ne veut
pas dire nulles infâme
non mais là bon jeu par eva comme sûrs
top mais je me demande si c'est pas avec
guy finalement qu'il a alors je dirais
pas mieux femmes dans le sens gros
avantage c'est peut-être lui qui s'est
mis après c'est un petit peu je sais pas
où il aperçoit qui est des 3 kg 3 caps
il me revient
ouais t'as raison sa récente yvan égal
mais bon est-ce qui va faire très pris
ce prix souvent là c'est vraiment à
raison je prendre 3 me de quévy rue 410
m guéant les quatre direct mais bon
monsieur
il prend des 5 ou qui est un peu la vie
peuvent calculer épreuve de rage et un
rouge et trois séries près de faire
glisser cette sanction des eaux kg 6
pourquoi pas à l'identique f5
parmi les races 5
je vois pas de combines mais bon pour
vous montrer par rogesa parce que les
5,2 drache 5 tu prends de l'espace c'est
bien joué ferme pas guéri plus tôt
aniche libye sur un terrain nouveau joie
redoutable sur la moitié de mon métier
de gris à gris libye coiffe un fou mais
qui est très fort il faut 10 il revient
pour tous les mauvais côtés des deux
joueurs s'agit pas de chute pas de
chance mais j'ai remarqué fac que même à
ce niveau là en fait dans cette position
là ça propose pas nulle envie de ça ou
votre iphone 4 tout ça propose pas
nulles fab pas ok pour quoi faire
je sais pas c'est un truc à moitié
amicale sur internet à une compétition à
enjeu mais je dis ok ça fait quand même
beaucoup
ouais c'est pas la pression instruments
prévisions armaggion semestre et c'est
en plus pour les parties sur internet
stressé tout le temps hu a fait la
renommée aux carrières à 14 ans ça va tu
veux dire que l'enjeu pas très grave en
fait vous faire des bonnes parties
études pas tu joues pour passer un pur
jeu n'importe quoi je pense
mais si les jours le choix entre entre
gagner un speech est saoul ou un tournoi
ils vont plutôt prendre le temps durs
même si le prix est moins fort je pense
peut-être aujourd'hui encore après quand
on verra dans ton trou et bien sûr non
mais non je parle actuel alors l'actuel
probablement mais il suffirait en faites
que ça compte pour le vélo et là ça
changerait tout mais après c'est pas du
tout pour dénigrer de cette religion
j'aime bien donc je trouve très agréable
à suivre tranquille on est chez nous
suivre ça on les voit show pleine partie
c'est bien c'est sympa puis hier on en
fait avec une première surprise dans
trois ans donc c'est possible ça il l'a
prouvé duda hier et ce qui est pas mal
aussi par rapport au format de blitz et
que ça permet de vraiment suivi la
partie puisque c'est vrai qu'en quand
ils font les tournois à un moment donné
le suis plus frais ford et on se prend
des séries de couleur gris ce qui est
quand même plus agréable abattre l'arbre
à commenter et à suivre du coup est ce
qu ont fait cavaliers satef 5 ce que
j'aime pas ou est ce qu'on fait roi je
pense juste que cette caisse est
tranquillise - robin pas en même temps
pourquoi on doit faire autre chose et
comme ça sur f5 je pense que je vais
manger manger faire une psy façon il se
passe pas grand chose pour le moment un
côté blanc mais bon je suis bien dans le
feeling de guy claude pas mal de coups
je propose qu'ils jouent au baby foot
est très heureux ouais bon ces petits
coups solides c'est pas la partie
d'avant où l'attaqué faire le hca page 5
non non non l'ail et les personnes qui
souhaitent et s'ils souhaitent quatre là
oui on est là quand fu est chargé en d4
tournée
derrière c'est bon alors on est bien là
ouais là on est au top là sur la
proposer nul d'ailleurs j'aurais proposé
aux droites cette jarre des jeux découle
j'étais bien là la petite partie
insipide noti2 tous là là on comprend ce
qui se passe c'est vous pas une tactique
ray de la partie on refuse l'échangé de
laon b 4-1 en coupe à leur arrivée ou
les offices des échanges mais c'est vrai
qu'on a des notions qui sont quasi voire
sable des six ouais je pense en fait
c'est dur de faire quelque chose avec
les blancs ta té ni légère activité mais
guérit de défendre des 4 f 5 tu dois
surveiller et du coustou pas tiqué
souffre à la fois défendre et attaquer
et faire un truc après l'attentât manqué
ses trois que sans nulle part et on
ressasse à leur bien à un truc c'est que
parfois si tu force trop ces partis
actuels te retrouves à les perdre
du pur un pion là ça va pas arriver mais
vrai regard il tente fois h5 foot et un
passé quasiment les blancs là qui ont
pressé financer les noirs qui sont bien
rencontrés puis dire et puis s'il est
pas mal pour faire ça on compterait mais
guérit quand il était jeune je vois très
tactique under est encore jeune mais là
quand il était très jeune mais il presse
info enfin il se passe quoi surprise
prise est fou d'elle je sais pas ce que
je me demande d'où une question
peut-être que faire un blocus avec
fouille b5 et c5 fuite
c'est quand même un pion ben oui tu vas
faire mais je pense oui même en toiture
a poussé quatre et b 5 contres
griffiths est en réunion à défiler je
serai bien voir de cette voie royale fut
trois sets
ouais je sais bien fou des rentes ai
vite que l'autre isaac tire bien tu
amènes rendre il faut repartir mais
peut-être un f3 parents vont et tu peux
faire recette fou dessin il faut
incarner est en fait à mon avis y jouer
fougue et trois c4 au moment opportun il
va peut-être gagné en fait le surf ou
les trois c4 le foot blanc enfin des
blancs ils vont faire un francis un truc
comme ça et il va balancer b5 question
est en train de faire et trier mieux je
sais pas assez bien joué
orange et 3 fautes mais mais ok tu as
déjà en interne elle en progrès on
enlevait le blocus on va faire b5
qu'est-ce que ça ces réunions
fantastique
leroy et fuite cette fois je cinquième
fois ok il n'avait pas le temps de faire
quand même ceci sous je sais pas quoi
passe en phase 5
je pense qu'ils auraient regagné un
thème pour la fête en faisant ça et
peut-être du coup le fossé caf était
plus fort qu'on gagne à tembo son bien
fondé de très bons jeux bravo très joli
il est donc vraiment ouvert deux
espagnols donc j'aimerais même et s'est
mis enfin on s'est longtemps qu'ils
jouent s'armer mais ici mis à jouer ça
beaucoup récemment la donc d'un jeu
c'est un vieux coup de karachi ont fait
retour d un essai gag sont guéris qu'un
joueur qui a une grosse grosse culture
ouais mais ça j'ai vu c'est parti dans
un mail est prédécesseur caspar mais
c'est une vieille partie mais j'ai trop
sympa le tour des années 80 le bâti à
l'est le regard pointu je connaissais
les parties normales fait ces trois
machin mais plus de trucs insipides quoi
non mais font que faut que manet il faut
que mambé soit sérieux parce que s'il
est ce tu vois là + 2 c'est pas encore
la crise mais moi non mais en plus le
contenu des parties s'est pas loupé
trois déjà été proscrit en fait à une
position de faire nul en force mais ça
peut être juste légèrement mieux pour
les blancs je sais que tu sais qu'aider
ktla je pense que l'idée c'est de se
rappeler life est un petit mouvement de
tête mais il a deux je pense que je sais
plus j'ai pas vu depuis longtemps
la sémantique sur le plein youtube
gaiman et c'est un diesel il s'en sent
la montée en puissance mais pas voilà
mais bon faut pas partir trop loin non
plus non mais c'est surtout le contenu
qui peut être inquiétant dans le sens où
guy assorti km2 très grosse partie et
s'il est en forme comme ça je pense pas
qu'il faille lui laisser trop de capri
va prendre confiance on va tous se
changer et kg soit à la fin mai la prime
b3 d'abord ok ok je suis toujours très
bizarre mais ok on va vite faire pour
cela je pense est d'appuyer sur les
points faibles des noirs ok donc ses
seins qui l'a pas sauvé le fou et ses
systèmes poli décembre sur près de 6000
km à 9,7 et peut-être tour des six ans
laisse b3 emprise et toi avez bien lu
rien fou prend b3 pourquoi pas et pour
ce tour des six maintenant qu'ils ont ça
en a besoin et s'il fait ses quatre en
fait ce couple un peu le fou du jeu il
va défendre ses pions et des traumas
juste monté droit il joue à tifra il
joue cette finale hier très ambitieux
plan de ses 5 ou attendre peut-être ta 3
2 pour renault bref de j'aime bien mais
bon si tu veux prendre le pion quand
même un jour même si on prend la toute
nouvelle fois 4 échanger ses 6 6 et
tokyo 5
si on peut améliorer voilà on est quatre
dans ces villages
est ce que les normes ne pas en fatigue
en place un peu de positions
on va peut-être des droits sur le
casse-noix f5 j'aime pas parce que tu
perds mirage étroit avec la 3g 5
surtout qu'il a fait à six pour faire 1
500 mah jong il est en train de dominer
la lala j'aime bien parce contre ces
pièces ça bouge pas il veut peut-être
faire tourner ses huit courses et c'est
pour ça que je sais pas vraiment on va
t'en douter loin j'ai copié ou quatre
peut-être sur la route on va le vénusien
grignote pour luncher chemin de le
mettre dans un tupperware fais tu là une
chanson man up mon gas assez chiant avec
akena monsieur chat des cinq je peux pas
le sort de riolo qui rigolent et qui
écrit à écrire il fait que des nuls avec
une petite tête de cap à quoi ok on va
s'adapter c'est pourquoi il m'a une
seule nul ce soir parce possible bref
quatre pas mal la raquette reposer du
affaires food et 5,4 je pense est quand
même en f4 sarthon les musulmans même
que ce soit en gardena tu penses qu'à
pas réussir à vraiment pressé pressé
moche mais bon soit d'autre 6 je
comprends qu'il ya des 4 maintenant
c'est la merde ignorant recettes
c'était faire tout reproche cinq noms
non non non non j'ai fait mon 10e si
c'etait plutot aux banquiers des cas
pour récupérer mais il ya peut être
emprunter 6 alors juste ridicule au
québec at bon quai d'orsay
mais il aura peut-être le temps de faire
un coup de cavaliers malin donc et donc
il doit tout est changé
il y avait reproduit je pense bouffe ou
froid 5 mai soit tombé cinq minutes il
va presser du vin peut presser un peu
pressés au québec j'ai trois jeux
peuvent apprendre le cadre là pascal
carbon prise mais toi des six tours des
quatre je pense à un jour tu veux faire
non mais peut-être c'est pas simplement
je ne savais que si tu pars pars là bas
il faut la défendre mais moi j'ai cinq
est ce que ceci dit je pense pas qu'il
faille prendre le 4 pour le droit de
prendre un jour optionnelle pas je
trouve c'est bien retourner sista temps
de retourner un peu la pente adverse il
prendra compte environ quand tu prends
en fait tu vas permettez chèque et tours
j'ai quatre peut-être échappé aux
réformes
bref cas j'aime bien ton coup mais bon
on peut juste passer notre tour avec les
normes trois chansons où on peut voir
transferts le cas van troyen eric
arachnima mais n'est pas censé être l'un
des meilleurs attaquants pour le moment
guéri prouve le contraire
ouais mais non mais je voulais attaque
aussi en fait les est ce qu'on dise et
quoi c'est juste qu'il serait une
mauvaise réputation et c'est tout mais
sinon il a ainsi plutôt offensif
dernièrement c'est pas non plus le plus
grand joueur d'attac de tous les temps
mais
en fait je pense tu aimerais tellement
et changer d'option 2 contre le pion à
elf et retrouvé avec cette finale qui
est plus si simple annuaire après 52 non
mais tu as tu l as il ya d'autres soucis
les faqs intel oracle a sans doute le
verger cisme déjà les noms je pense que
jamais juger si c'est ce que tu vas
faire aussi sa bonne escient et germain
lamonde où tu peux te prendre aussi tout
retour échec tout rage suite attaqué ton
pions h5 forcé le pion à venir revenir
avec la lame au top je peux être très
envie de faire torah je suis match à
raymond du coup le roi reviendrait sur
la 7ème donc peut-être on le chasse plus
après versé par pour ça bah je pense le
biais des progressistes maintenant faut
pas qu'ils aient chassé de thoras est ok
mais ch'est qui est peut-être poussé le
moment quoique cher comment si on pousse
tu reprends mon sens un peu coup on
marque pour 17 ans sur la mutuelle il
pourra parler y en a et 6 mai pointe
taillon des six maurice auprès de cinq
tours j ça que moi donc il y aura aussi
d'autres on ne peut pas faire mieux que
ça vous dit encore vraiment bien je
crois qu'il trouve ma mais a très bien
défendu
défaut quittant ton truc un branchement
pas l'intention y est on prend sur le 8e
but est obligé parce qu'on vérifie sur
35 maintenant j'aurai bien ou mal parce
qu'il fasse froid et fluide seul coup tu
as demandé si ce qui menace il y avait
cinq échecs qu'ils elles s'arrêtent pour
17 franchir je vois pas la 3g pendant
sept ans il va donc je suis sûr perdre
on discute mais tour cette lan ont voulu
changer sa bombe
en tous les cas sur un dessin qui fait
tourner cette tour des six tours assiste
d'ailleurs au 6ème tour à 6 73 17 en
tant que gestionnaire au sein du g7 de
jeu j'ai pas compris qu'il ait pas trois
ans plus tard je trouve en vente soient
pas contents de leur couper mais après
que j'ai rien vu de concret mais peut
être salée pas un truc qui m'échappe
mais après tu la gagnes pas jugé bon
weekend du tour b 4 1 et angers 4 et ma
chance doit être ferme et 6 non mais
c'est pas sera stockée et je suis saisi
sur ce choix nul mais bon c'est plus du
tout la même truc trivial congé c'est
tout
savard est logique hein mais après
beaucoup hausse des recettes
je sais pas trop j'avais étrangers 7 par
intuition ta réussite huras est parfois
avec d'autres hésitent elle s'est aussi
chargé de porter secours à jouer si je 2
the tempo prochain pas content et il
veut prolonger 6 avec le royaume ont
donné retaper à 5 avec la tour qui sait
nous avons un à temps passe si vite que
ça parce que le truc c'est que je suis
roi proche des six ben y'a roi rachat
voilà mais bon tant pis ok c'est bien
joué puisque tourache 6 non je suis fait
un nul non tu peux pas la gagner c'est
bon en pivot chinois entre 3 et 5 ans
allemandes seul coup tu peux tenter
c'est vrai j'ai cinq tours g41 encadrer
son bon là il est trop proche
ça c'est nul théorique session il trop
proche du coin mais joli final
ouais c'est son bon bon mais là ils
l'embêtaient ouais il a posé il ya posé
des petits problèmes et voir défense
passive a plein de manières de défendre
sa bombe à vous tous voir quoi mais bon
les griffes et continue à faire tourner
la pendule là je pense pas qu'on puisse
dire qu'il se fait tourner la pendule à
proprement dire une colle devancé gagner
je crois aux marrons mignon il ne
voulait pas proposé nul face au moc et
c3 s'attendent viennoise mais peut être
4 6 4 j'ai trois pressions et des
citoyens domaine du dessin que les
instruments soient légalisés sa
baignoire
ouais je sais qu'au pdci sont en bonne
voie
c'était non inscrits devaient de toucher
3 quand même des prix mauvaise affaire
du passé ça en fait le plus en fait tu
prends le risque de guerre fin pour de
chance tu prends une semi chance quand
tu es tu as une chance sur mille mais
bon tu prends la chance il n'y a pas eu
quatre la sq en fait si tu viens
bouffémont fou je prendrai peut-être de
f
ok le cas tu fais quoi en fait et
suprend et que tes chansons tu vas être
mindshare petit ami qui fait quoi en
fait sur leucate
peut-être plus mal en fait moi je pense
bêtement ba écoute et on avait tous un
bond de 24 coups critiques en tout cas
un truc surtout enfin tu veux faire dame
prend tout reprend il faut prendre 4 et
tu vas te retrouver avec mes maîtres je
me tais toi tu vas pas de prendre quatre
à mais ok c'est pas perdant meilleur tu
es tu à gaspiller les blancs quoi bon
bein je vous cavaliers à 5-5 kébé 3eme
foulée 6 4 6 4
mais pas sûr qu'ils avaient lieu 5 et 5
7 fois et 400 us ont mis presque sur le
toit il se fait un gros début on a bien
réfléchi
il sort un gros début de match fab
c'est un gros début de match point en
fait la france s'arrête là mais c'est
vrai qu'il est assez impressionnant pour
le moment ou trois je pense là dessus
pour le moment il est assez
impressionnant et qu'elle juge ouais
ouais
le petit aniche verser un prénom sympa
aniche 1 ne connais pas d'autres moi non
plus je vous un joli prénom
j'aime bien les prénoms courts alors
j'ai fait ce qu'il est d'origine
népalaise qui est qu'est ce qui se passe
avec le népal en fait il un truc avec le
népal
ouais il ya un truc avec le népal écoute
je sais pas déjà je sais qu'ils parlent
des palais
ça c'est sûr bon il n'y a pas de la
merde transition possible des sens de
faire il n'est pas laid on ne connaît
pas l'agent sont pas toujours pris son
père est né pas les attend mais je peux
les regarder un petit coup de wikipédia
blessé le mot culture
allez c'est pas ces rares aux échecs les
népalais et sa mère juste ça je sais
c'est rare tout court en fait leur
drapeau et très marrant d'ailleurs c'est
pas un rectangle un arbre a poussé la
fourmi filiale n'était grand malheureuse
de 14 ans et sept mois
locallife il est né à saint pétersbourg
94 mère la mère russe olga et nathalie
zfs asa et en 2002 donc les huit ans il
ya des ménages au japon et bien vécu
jusqu'en 2008 jusqu'a ces 14 ans on m'a
pris par m et pas depuis février 2008
jerry de famille advini viva riches
riches aux pays bas où son père
travaille la recherche des consultants
comme fondation jeu
il a 2 6 2 soeurs voilà et puis c'est
marie alors bon et wade pour mam et
enfin je n'essaye pas de retour et
hermès
ouais je vois un mur voiture qu'il
dirige ou bien du bon attendus pour le
groupe bouygues a peut être payé show
mamère elle est un peu petit budapest où
ça se passe
de 3,3 poison tout en est à 3 pts c'est
pas faux de quel jeune couple charmant
le pion et durant le pion et je sais
plus si je ferais keynote accueilli ces
prises freeski et ses trois à cinq un
truc comme ça mais pris ce prix ça car
lieu 5 et la faire plonger l'action
qu'il parlait de cochonnailles quoi mais
je suis pas sûr avec les blancs genre tu
fais tout raciste ou raffy 6 après
classique quais du coup l'idée de
cavalière à quatre c'est de forcer fois
cette pas à forcer pour éviter tout
raciste ou racistes en fait par l'une
des idées de kanata parce qu'en fait tu
suivais tour à six cavaliers à 4,1 prix
va te faire fois cette année sa tour et
ça fera un gros surnom sur le roi alors
que là du coup s'il garde la torah 8
leurs fonds à 7 serait pas très bien
placé mais je passe il a joué des tours
à 6 du coup je suis pas sûr évidemment
j'ai un peu étudié ce truc-là nouveau
c'est étrange
tu t'es dit ok je file un pion deuxième
coup forcément si tu m'as trahi existe
moi dès que j'ai vu ça je me suis dit
tiens c'est une ouverture pour moi quoi
un budget bien mais est-ce que tu files
le pion aux sacs et tu te laisses
s'attaquer ton propre cavaliers donc
quelque part tu te dis il faudrait faire
des 4,5 direct non tu as tu mets ton
cavaillon m6 pour qu'il soit sous le
sous le feu des chenilles que du coup il
change de plan et je paye tout raciste
puisque justement que le fou le fou de
cases noires à l'attaqué mais fois de
bien jouer j'ai vu une partie où il ya
eu foule katura 6 g iii le vainqueur 1
et font songer de liste fait mater en 22
coups enfin la partie sur la chaîne
d'ailleurs l'occasion parti que j'avais
trouvé dans l'excellent livre simpl
chess les échecs simple mais en fait moi
je préfère toujours les blancs genre de
position
[Musique]
le sous-total un terrain il ya plein de
petites variantes l'élan croque un coup
géniaux j'aime pas ça en fait du côté du
coup et les larmes tu peut tricoter
en fait j'ai surtout rendre l'option
avec les blancs prochaine mais après tu
as une variante retirer quoi j'étais
vraiment bien mais bon faut être précis
il faut se rappeler de tous les défauts
comme t'as pas que ça à faire que de te
rappeler de tous de budapest ce que
peuvent toujours passer la montagne les
rangs du commun comme ça comme le
budapest valamas candidat c'est un peu
la même chose
cette ouverture un peu pourri mais ça
c'est bien ma mais là c'est la première
partie où il joue vraiment bien
il a enfin jeu là mais qui quoi je dois
de rendre notre partout c'est fou quand
même barre mais alors on débranche peut
défendre la non plus mais bon je préfère
ça à mon tour mais te donne un pion
ferit eux c'est comme s'ils te jette un
gant à la gueule et que toi tu ce qu'ils
veulent augmenter ce qu'ils faisaient
j'ai revu un coup de vendre les oiseaux
qui passent le doigt mais du coup bien
joué et thurau sûr à trois fois pour
toujours ce problème japonais de 10,5
pts et 5 15 jours constant je crois que
c'est ça qui est marrant je dois avoir
dû des 5 pouces et 5 tours eu six d'un
proche parent est donc mes bras justice
pour l'instant ça va mais à l'abri de ça
mais c'est untel va surveiller tout le
monde et surtout contre man et j'ai
envie de sur david parra viennent
d'ailleurs qui est connecté là le fameux
celui qui avait fait la partie de fulham
j'ai trois champs
demande si les blancs sont mieux du rêve
à lui un jour du oui/non je suis pas sûr
at avantage l'espace d'un côté est à
perdre de fou de l'autre et les fous ils
parlent bah ouais bon alors je me suis
dit on n'est qu'un bon bâillon mois dans
la bouche
il repart avec la tour 1 pas bête
bakchich elop points du lou chaque des
fois ça se jouera ce but de butt
mais toi tu penses tu veux tout liquider
essayer de faire après d'un vrai damas
de réussir à jamais dans le nord qui va
s'introduire à dire tu gagnes et la
colonne à michael douglas réagencer fab
gamerizon fou je me sens très très
grisant ce soir on est dehors et on a
les geôles d'alger théâtre en suisse le
thème ta tâche
ok ok tu veux jouer quoi il veut le
chantre des fois qu'ils aient eu 2 kg 2
et je peux moi mais cette part peut-être
devoir faire tour alain rey ou prendre
effet retour f4 et c'est intéressant
enfin je sais pas trop ce que ça donne
balazs mine d'infos question quel
suspense quel est le sentiment je fais
pas de débat pas ça c'est le genre de
partie que je serai sûr de perdre contre
mam est en fait c'est c'est hyper dur à
jouer puisque du coup tu as pris
beaucoup d espace mais si un jour tu te
fait que montrer disney offre
ouais ok il faut surtout surveiller des
c'est vraiment le truc tu veux pas
qu'ils rient
ahtisaari twin y habituerons hockey
donne deux nocturnes et mes affaires et
noir c'est pas si dynamique que ça donc
les pistes a pas grand chose à faire ce
que j'ai ici ce qui passe d'une rupture
cette même rivière fu b2 il dit ça que
ça marche pas mal de chose d'autre à
faire donc c'est pas si agréable pour
les normands truc à fond contre guiry
c'est sûr mais contre nous je crois que
tout est agréable quand l'autre côté à
faire très attention à pas se prendre un
x 5 enfilade un jour c'est un genre de
piège de fouine ça qui peut oublier
je parle des pièges je vais peut-être g6
maintenant et surprend des six fois et 6
d'être notre rupture
je raisonne coup de vent je peux ça le
terrible mais le trailer a mis la
pression sur catane mais tu vois ok ce
qu'on peut j'ai pas être prend des
risques en même temps des huit touchés
toi
mais bon il est pris suis là ok on y va
lâcher le 4 passes et sur henry aussi
fait un hyper compliqué la position
femmes c'est le bordel là c'est très
complexe
en effet quand il fait tour
je sais pas toi et perso j'ai toujours
énormément de mal je sais position avec
les blancs as possible ce soit ce retour
de groupauto d'un coup quoi une sorte de
patate chaude l'homme et puis tu as tes
pièces qui sont protégés de partout à
l'el dames sont éloignés du jeu fatiha
j'aime bien avoir des trucs compact voix
c'est dur à jouer ces trucs là puis
surtout que tu dois je dois vraiment
aller prendre dès 6h je crois battus 4 1
jeudi en c3 ou variera maintenant c'est
trois ouais c'est pas mal joué en fait
qu'est c3 tu veux faire tomber cette est
peut-être tout reprendre tout reprend à
vii après tu resteras et d'amd cinq
échecs tu vois un truc comme ça
très en forme ce quoi j suite investi le
web
mais bon il comprend dans tu veux pas tu
peux pas tu peux pas rester assis et et
attentats soit c'est un copain qui est
l'expression russie qui n'est qu'à lui
un mini 10 est resté assis fumée
qu'attend uturbey 8 mai tombent et je
crois qu'il y avait un problème qui
demeure maths à la fin bombay - la
pression je passe quoi que ça suffira
mais bon il était plutôt du bon côté là
tu tu joues pour au pire faire nîmes ils
sûrement faire venir peut être fait
tourbe et 8 c'était change tout et tu
prends la nulle non
quoique pourquoi je tadjou et ajuste h3
aussi non mais les deux jeunes c'est une
trente secondes de plus c'est un joug du
cahier des 5 mai par exemple comme ça
marron continuation tourne plus après tu
fais quoi j'ai trois peut-être une
oeuvre de roy norme est ok je suis je
parlais rassurer l'homme m mais bon
c'est encore une petite victoire
psychologique dans le sens où malgré
tout une position très complexe et c'est
lui qui finit par pressé non mais
vraiment super bien ce soir et guérir
pas franchement c'est g4s de 4,6 g 4 42e
bon faut sortir des cats
ok commence agence patrick ce qui fait
qu'à l'e3 il va devenir tu peux pas te
permettre à laquelle est encore mieux
est ce que ma bouffe ne sort c'est
gagnable
je dis pas que c'est gagnant gagnant 3 e
de roi des 3 ou 1 mais peut-être il te
manque un coût pour un contrôle est-ce
que quand tu contourne tu te rend pas
fou et 5 du coût soit détenu mhkd à fond
f4 didier cros qu'il varie en effet de 4
kg rares bons à 3 074 mètres 3-0 en
partie décisive ses boubous pas karin
gérard qu'il a mis 41 couvre comprendre
que les juges écartent un petit peu tard
mais mieux vaut tard que jamais non mais
c'est honnêtement c'est je veux pas
exagérer ni rien mais le niveau qui est
en train de montrer ses seins y voit on
est avec lequel tu peux arrêter les
meilleurs glisseurs du monde mise à part
carl celles qu'ils ont connues de toute
façon au dessus mais je pense qu'en
jouant comme ça tu peux même inquiété un
haka 1 puisque ça regardez comme très
solide y a pas d'erreur tactique
stratégiquement c'est bien joué les
finales elles sont bien pressé
impressionnant d'abord ma mais il doit
décider de son répertoire bail que je
prend peut-être c'est un petit peu par
dessus la jambe
mais bon malgré tout fallu on a vu des
joueurs qu'on ne parle je suis agent
mais en ayant un écart tutu défonçage
arrive c'est quand même j'ai quand même
prendre au milieu de juin
et puis en plus les azéris est décédé
joueurs qui sont des factions débiteur à
et mérite donc je pense qu'il peut faire
tuer ilan il peut être dangereux avec un
répertoire bild c'est sur ma mère est
retournée dans le mixeur messieurs leur
c4 caisse peut être la première à la
petit peu première banderille qui est en
train de placer la non dans le match ok
mais tu dois faire ça
qui est ce être le four pas ce que tu es
fou 3 à 5 tours h4 tu t'en vas truc
aussi bizarre que ça robin poussières -
pas prêtes à celui plaisait pas du goût
des je ne peux pas y est d'être en l'air
je fais aussi des parents est ce qu'on
peut essayer de faire jordan 17 tours
des huit cavaliers f5 et les quatre
façons sa session de tir chez à 100
contre et on sait que des proies pour
l'instant ni fébrile et je trouve plus
quand ce fut au tour de lui qu'il ya
plus personne sur l'année en diagonale
enfin c'est bien ça généralement tu es
heureux quoi qui est pendu à ces
horribles en listant il voudra trouve
aussi passif à 100 m libre à ce quatre
là c'est la catastrophe roulement
georges des toits des conneries comme ça
blanc noir de pire de moderne avec les
blancs becs et 3g 3 mais tu as a way
road
j'ai l'impression que qu'on à faire un
mamediarov en mode en mode cariat king
qui m'a pas l'air d'être et 7 pas en
forme mais sur maman plus mauvais choix
sur internet
on n'a jamais trop vite sur le même
débat et son fameux débat de détroit
déclare mes souvenirs c'est je pense un
des murs 800 membres en réel yamani la
queue de 1830 il n'a pas été très en
forme
non mais bon j'espère samaranch est
sourd en glissant il n'a pas il n'ya pas
il n'a pas impressionné ses îles et fm
bien derrière n'a qu'à m il ya quand
même pas été si impressionnant que ça
et hélas pour le moment et gris quand
même envie c'est bon aussi un autre
c'est sûr et bien réputé et du coup dans
ce carré dijoux il joue il joue dans le
carré en bas à gauche et s'équipent dans
le car en bas à gauche
c'est alors je sais qu'en demi après ses
2 c c'est du côté de mv elle n'a calé en
lorgnant ouais c'est les vents et du
coup ça peut être un beau match aussi un
petit les veaux un père un joli quarts
de finale toute façon y avoir que des
jolies quart le quart le plus
déséquilibré ça va être gritche dargaud
mais maisons aux toits sont aigris tube
ça aurait été déséquilibré face à
n'importe qui dans notre côté donc j'ai
envie de dire ça ne change rien ça ne
change rien mais guérit tout qui fait un
peu partie d'épouvantail manon côté
droit avant c'était cardiaque hier même
s'il ya un regret
si ce terrifiant et demie jouera le
vainqueur de wesley so contre je sais
pas si tu as un si tu peux regarder
femmes
maintenant je sais pas je te faisais tu
as en avoir bien fait là mais c'est qui
c'est le joueur qui manque en fait parce
que date
oui image annonce à cette affaire bah en
fait c'est au km louis d'emballage ou en
bois allez on cherche contre qui joue
sow ouais moi et on va peut-être plus
dur dans le tchat ce sens il suffit de
repasser tous les joueurs qualifiés dans
notre esprit c'est forcément un match
qu'on a vu parce que les deux matches
qu'on a ratées c'est un livre est exact
donc sauvy dit visite qui va te faire à
mon avis explosé en tout cas si je joue
comme il a joué le la semaine dernière
il va même pas y avoir match et je pense
que dans un match sont gris tchouk
sigrid chouquet est dans une forme
correcte qui 1 6 1 quand même assez
important
il devrait être quand même favori ce
serait sympa d'avoir un petit et du coup
on pourrait peut-être faire des
commentaires à 3 en finale avec lada mon
avis s'ils ont malgré tout qu'en finale
je pense que ça peut être on peut se
faire une soirée très sympa tigre
hitchock mvl pendant la pause on verra
flotte compte téléphone qui n'a pas
regardé des fichiers quoi épater
ouverture images france et 5 l'attention
c'est vrai qu'il ya la place pour great
food pour aller en face à lui après la
défaite de gravelines quand même bien de
chroniques de karim ziani à même la
route
c'est peut-être le favori du tournoi les
mecs se fait éliminer passe un peu comme
du rock aux cantates federer qui se fait
éliminer
enfin ça tout vaut quand même le tableau
1 je respire mieux c'est bien joué faux
h 6 qu'est-ce qui vous bien ce soir guy
quand même fable sur ton plus dans les
rues de tous les côtés non mais c'est
précis c'est
mais c'est du haut niveau en fait quand
même là de toute façon même quand même
un mât mais qui prend le match un peu de
côté ou quoi site si tu lui mets 5 5 1
avec deux nuls cas de victoire à
l'inversé
mais c'est lourd c'est il est à 3000 ans
guy hoquet joue une jeune femme joue un
truc non mais non les bijoux répertoire
enfin lafarge et ses gaffes retrouver
ses quatre très bien du moment
ces quatre là très bien joué l'armée ok
il connaît ils connaissent tous en plus
j'avais étudié fait très attention
oui c'est moi en fait de ma vie ajouté
un truc de merde là je connais tous quoi
nous envie de me taper tout raciste qui
avait quatre bien joué là cette mère de
ces quatre événements je connais est
fantastique en fait je suis un
spécialiste de merde tu fais ton ce
serait des changes est double 1 ouais
parce qu'un surveillant tout va mieux
voici les grands pions prend en patron
oui tu va l'empêcher tu as joué un deux
contre un de l'autre côté après de mode
et puis si ça peut faire d'un ne
disparaît pas mal
notre agent car à noter on me dit que
chess calme était m et emma mais en gros
favoris avec 68 % très grosse différence
ça se fait c'est peut-être la semaine
des as underdogs jamais de surprise et
là tout d'un coup sur coup on peut en
avoir deux ouais mais là bon pour rester
cinq ans avance oui pour toi mais
l'algorithme il se trompe jamais
normalement dernier c'était comme un
paul le poulpe était sur l'art que des
surprises vie disent qu'ils éliminent
soa mvl chi minh a car c'est génial
d'être avec des messieurs qui marche pas
mal l'ol votent habituellement wii j'ai
nommé les fêtes était juste en p2p nord
oues et c'est de la merde en fait mais
bon faut que les blancs connaissent mais
le truc c'est que mon niveau ça se joue
mais pas à passer voilà quoi surtout que
guy a pu penser parce que ma mais il est
dans les bases avec cette ouverture donc
siguiri c'est apparaît sérieusement et
j'ai l'impression qu'il est plus il est
venu avec beaucoup de conviction dans ce
match mais v'là de me disais que c'était
pas une consigne compétition si anodine
en fait pour les sponsors
bizarrement quelques unes sont battus
cherche des sponsors
sebastian pas ce qu'il dit c'est un peu
l'équivalent d'un championnat du monde
des échecs sur internet officiers pas
qu'elle prend un seul jeu phare qu'est
points 6 crise est finie je reprends
d'un grand rush 8
je vais reprendre et ça te fais ça c'est
surtout absence j'ai vu kg 5 me ouais
donc je disais femme sait pas dire pour
les pour les sponsors et d'un autre côté
quand tu gagnes ça tu peux dire c est
champion du monde dans la porte
un équivalent bas alors qu'il ya plein
de tournage pas tu gagnes viennent par
exemple au québec a gagné mais du coup
une visée à ce droit ce niveau là c'est
un truc intéressant par exemple pour
karine il pensait carrier qui n'est pas
le truc très au sérieux comme il a des
sponsors des machins
qui est de 101 khadir faut ici sur ces 7
dans une bande bien sûr évident qu'il
est prend 17
comme tous les côtés bon jeu comme tu
sais toi il est auteur d'un best of mais
bon ça peut sortir d'affaires 4 à nous
les fans cogné des circuits pour les
pcistes les avancées qui est sympa quand
bien même mais j'ai trois peut-être on
écoute
non j'ai trois dans les têtes des noms
mais leur dame b 4 c'est déjà une option
[Musique]
le multi est une option
quand tu vas le faire tour 1 le maire
non dans mes quatre vérités d'hier dame
prend huit tours c'est 8 1
iliad à me 4/5 originales comme un air
de vue
la shoah il faut faire dans les quatre
années qui aura réussi à bloquer mais
c'est qu'il prend 17
il les joue trop facile mais bon ça que
j'avais dis moi même aux élites mais bon
moi je joue pas je commente après je
peux comprendre à imane au score et tout
mais ça peut être un tournant du match
fut la femme
non mesdames des caps ça va quand même
on défende battant l'un alghero
concentriques en 17 ans de tous puisque
c'est pas très grave on va pas perdre
mes chers bembe cap qui comprend 17
tours je sais pas fortuite
très bien non mais je dois moi qui
cherche un truc plus ok c'est même
esprit sûrement mieux mais non il ya
encore d'un concert très bizarre et
jusqu'à 8,5 tempo est un peu obligé le
compte d'un ouvrage aux âmes à charlotte
game il a joué en 0,6 centièmes de
seconde donc c'est quand même assez près
quoi battu adverse était surpris
et tu pense qu'il a tout calculé à c'est
quand même neuf bagues et il a passé
deux minutes sur son groupe bkc plus
fort d'ailleurs pour une raison x ou y
carrément ses cinq jeux palmer par les
mieux placés vraiment mauvais mais
pendant qu'on chantait j'ai 4 ans mais
bon tout est faux coach aussi non la b
non du coup je sais pas je m'approche
d'euros atteint dans ma chambre deux
heures et quelques points coulom
peut-être tester juste rien on peut
continuer à chirac le roi j'ai encore
des preuves non pas des trois cinquièmes
de ganges
non je vais faire tourner quoi ces camps
de base
j'avais peut-être piège que mais ok h2o
de faire du domicile pas évident en
famille ouais je me pendre comme ça là
je pense qu'il faut que m'avait saisi sa
chance et qu'il la gagne ça lasse il
veut non mais gagner c'est dur ouais
mais écoute c'est mam et un instant de
la magie de la part de ma mais dans ce
genre de position fabre m non c'est là
qu'on se bouge le tournoi dames c'est un
battant l'allemagne in my fab
vrai c'est vrai que c'est parti un plan
ans succède un truc si gagnant
et où
[Musique]
et pour un peu bas direct mal autant fab
fabienne bientôt il va habiter toutes
les coupes des âmes kg 4 peut-être
souvent répété d'être faut répéter la
grille a été dit a tenté une chute est
que le roi mais je crois pas je crois
qu'il va rester sur ce qui a tout
intérêt à répéter fabi mène de quatre
points il un peu raté la partie là nul
c'est pas si mal
t'as pas forcément de raisons ici de de
péter un plomb et de risquer de perdre
tu va le remettre dans le match tu perds
un mois que l'on peut pas trop faire ce
même quai gk3 des deux bons pour iliad
après 22h à bouger avec est possible
donc
donc ça non
la boit votre mamie regarde 2003 mais
bon c'est une marche pas je croyais
avoir des deux d'un prof de josélito
reprend ça ne marche pas il ya même du
poireau gagner mais bon kit occasions
ratées par guy parmelin ouais mais trois
noms mais pas un même toit afin de ne
plus être pour mam et n'ont pas vraiment
donné tu peux pas remercier tous mes
fans ce match après non mais en fait
j'aime pas je vais dire pourquoi parce
qu'en fait si tu prends cette
compétition peu au sérieux juste
n'accepte pas de jouer parce que plus ou
moins tout le monde la prenne au sérieux
jusqu'ici 1 c'est le premier joueur qui
prend il y en a qui ont pas vraiment
leur répertoire répertoire mais ok ils
ont quand même fait des trucs très
correcte et c'est le premier qui se
moque un peu de tu vois même pas trop
mais c'est marrant j'ai senti très vite
qu'ils sont en tête dès la ronde en
aurons deux je veux par dessus la jambe
j'aime pas je ne sais même pas ce qu'il
a fait dire ça en fait mais je sais pas
j'ai senti un truc mais mon pass point
com ou alors peut-être comme ça se passe
mal il s'est vite des cours fin par ok
peut-être ça aussi c'est le test de
chance une des seules chances pour venir
te dis ok si je gagne un jour âge 3 le
mec depuis tout petit et les puis c'est
un truc pour l'avenir quoi peut-être que
le troll je vois tu le vois tu me parles
2 h 3 août fait nul contre h3 juste et
wolf un voile alors qu'en réalité tu
peux permet avec les blés noirs les
blancs je crois c'est cette posture de
marque un point de serveurs d'accueillir
mont boisé alors là en plus c'est moins
pire que servir la cuire de faire ça je
pense c'est juste servir une seconde
balle en fête en voiture on sort une
seconde balle parce que je garde quand
même l'avantagé d'être fat et mieux
après je crois et clément tu as toujours
ton coup de plus au respect du cahier g5
nom de visa remplacent m parce que j'ai
cinq seront fait quoi mais c'est une
réussite soit je crois finalement du
coup on a parlé trop vite
ben oui et non ça change rien ou c'est
pas hyper correct non ça change et à ce
niveau là mais après c'est trop tard
[Musique]
oui non mais je comprends bien non mais
bon comme on disait à je crois c'est pas
non plus non mais assure jacques galy
ben non mais c'est pas grave
enfin sur la grotte c'est vraiment
mauvais enfin un exemple que les que les
internautes connaissent dans l'alcôve tu
retiens vraiment une balle dans le pied
quoi je les trouve partout je crois vous
dites encore et c'est comme si tu avais
des noirs les tâches 3 qui pourra
toujours servir braquage et quatre dans
certains cas comme là on serait bien dit
qu'il y avait quatre pas mal non mais
cccc savent à quoi ces salles à utiliser
des expressions du mur tu as donc ouais
cette petite position fab est ce que
c'est si grave grave si on fait foule 6
je pense à 2,5 et tu vas perdre le pion
bessette ouais voilà bon est-ce qu'on
est pas un peu obligé de rose adams et 7
le gaipes de tomber demain c'est
l'esprit par giugiaro 600 fait
clairement tu veux je l'entends
développement en compte et c'est se fout
des cinq qui est très chiant et tu
prépares peut-être la poussée du plan b
why not peut-être pas trop vite
à sochaux on fait trop vite coup franc
de cinq tours à 7
il est déjà actif comme ça voilà c'est
une occasion à la pour moi il faut pas
la rater c'est la femme est situé sur un
sur un coup comme dan b3 bon j'ai fait
une connerie en mairie comme ces quatre
ça peut être une idée les mecs
rediffusion assez joué mais un coup
comme ces quatre ça peut être une idée
je pensais pas qu'ils feraient ça pour
rendre le pion supprimer le fou et faire
du faux ici c'est s'activent à fond bon
peut-être d'amnesty c'est tout
what's wrong
ensemble ces sept
attends attends ya aussi des trucs mal
ça marche pas un truc accueil
provocatrice il faut regarder de temps
en temps ne fonctionne pas du tout
nouveau ton coin oui mais bon ça vous
prend 1,6 d'abord meilleur c'est ce truc
qui peuvent traîner aussi parfois trucs
un peu bizarres comme ça et dames 16
paraît logique ou dames 7 way
dans le même esprit un mais elle fait
c'est de simplifier et bon c'est vrai
qu'on n'est pas très contente des
banques
outre la colonne d où la seule que nous
verte ils ont fondé 5
mais bon c'est pas encore encore cuit
quand même loin de là bon puisqu'il est
prévu sur il faut prendre le 6
ça me prendra me prends tout reprend kg
5 si on fait tous rêver si c'était juste
5 et tout re 5 4 ça donne pas et donc je
vous posais ce niveau là et je prends un
truc
ouais mais je le prendrai bien son
destin et a fait des cinq peut-être
c'est trop grave dans le tube aspects du
jeu sur sa sandale bloquant des sites
il mange mange tu peux passer quatre
intermédiaires aussi à tour maintenant
c4 et c4 c4 et scoring
c'est quand que ça reprend un honneur
d'être français ça me prend et pour le
stratégiste
je veux aussi rendre la qualité et vont
donner la qualité de cinq mois
5 le prendre mais bon ok une baisse à 3
60 il est mal quand même
tu peux y mettre le chaos régnant à vii
pour colmater j'aime pas trop ce terme
est un peu colmater de garder un oeil
sur le pion sur le pur us 5
quel peut-être faire ces quatre
intermédiaires avec lui devant windows
et l'autre en b3 puis on prend le statut
et on prend 1,4 d'abord est de tu as
tenté ça parce que tout autre truc
normal t on trop mal et que là tu crées
un petit déséquilibre mais que ce plan
peut d'ailleurs y fait léser quattron
partir plus tôt mais bon on ne va pas
tracer le petit ayew 5 avec m j'y pense
je me fourchette c6 et devenir rct même
idée ouais moi il est plus accroché tant
ses 6 non ça c'est si bon tu pas encore
baker
en rappel bien l'homme
ça j'y crois pas du tout pour les noirs
mais bon avec imams et qui revient enfin
non mais en fait le parti d'avant se
posera toujours incroyable mais la loge
3 et fertilité façon c'était étonnant de
voir ma mais enfin j'ai du mal à
imaginer ma mais perdre le match comme
ça tu as sans son feedback enfin récents
combats en tout cas difficile là pour
aniche un jet tours bkb des salariés sur
quatre tours de cas autour b4 direct nos
jours et lui a prêté le cavalier en c4
mais bon chemin
ok c'était sur lauquet va quand même
menacé pris ce prix c4 et c3 et c2 quoi
et dames
mesdames d'en but mais doivent avoir le
temps de revenir juste à temps noëlle
renaude attend le bus quand tu arrives
en c3 le roi arrive en d3 et ce sera fou
je pense caniche peut quasiment
abandonné la fable j'ai mangé depuis le
tarmac mais je veux voir absolument faux
droit qui vient manger les uns après les
autres on va où je peux en voir moment
recevoir ses deux mains pour toi moi mon
venin parfois d'un motive ce nom c'est
panique à l'idée de plates vrai mais je
repense à la pause
ou encore je reste encore douze minutes
favin n'y a pas de pas de pause en d4
gaming 6
guillaume faroult système de l'ong
chigata bien turgot rindt ouah ouah ça
va je un peu quand j'étais ado s'est
situé pour le chip
non en fait je suis pas maso lequel est
montré pour départager les quatre ans je
crois que ça vient d'avoir notre cloud
j'ai beaucoup hésité
j'ai vu les parties morose et beach qui
jouait sa a si souvent et me l'a dit nos
visites ch mais alors bon je vais à
l'époque l'avenir entre d'autorité que
c'est con que je préside et j'avais
quelques partis en tête et aller je vous
donne pas plutôt pas mal d'ailleurs
broz évitait c'était sympa c'était bien
ça manque un jour quand même année
machin qui en furent repris le flambeau
[Musique]
d'une charte l'histoire partie retombés
du groupe droite en voudrez mais c'est
une autre époque aussi un bon mais
d'accord mais d'environ 95 c'est pas
censé être une ouverture d'un clip oui
mais c'est sur mais bon il avait perdu
contre vlad noms mêlant permet mais bon
le seul à une feuille les bus de
massacrer anhorn trouver dès l'aube du
moins j'ai perdu contre eux pelade mais
après les knicks était de la mairie le
conduire à sa défaite 1 0
il avait dix modèles disposant d une
chaise 4 5 et 4 motorisations 10-19
jones blenders points marqués il est pas
terrible mais c'est sacré pour la phase
d'entraînement ainsi c'était une partie
je pense quand il jouait le match russie
coupe du monde russie reste du monde en
2002 la hougue arriver dans n'importe
quoi et à star rapide et il avait joué
quatre ou cinq quilles f3 espagnole
classique les mini la partie là
et donc de callas 3 et là il m'a l'air
en commentaire à houston play très fort
questionne marque un petit geste plein
d'europe 1 non c'est juste un pion j'ai
pas vu encore en des années mr des pions
grand plongeon voilà cette position fait
c'est assez insipide dans de nouveaux
jobs pour calmer un peu le jeu et que ça
se passe est pas mal les positions
insipide à leur tour d2 autour des cages
pour des deux ans il ya petit avantage
blanc ou sait rien du tout la tournée je
faisais vraiment juge votre territoire
des caps et 5 orientée si ce n'est pas
tant des deux mois tu couvres le pion b2
avec sur des domaines après trois points
d'écart ça après le match d'hier en fait
tu te on est tellement pas l'habitude
qui est des retournements quoi que ce
soit que maintenant du coup ce match là
c'est vrai que ça donne espoir pour le
genre pour tout le monde ce que tu te
dis ok et finalement trois points en
bullet us est facile à rattraper n'y a
pas trop d'écart
la dynamique de ce match peut vraiment
tourné d'un moment à l'autre et ça tout
est possible il fait un genre d'
attaques de minorités il veut peut-être
eu avec à cinq là non c'est bien nous
posent des questions
ok prise de faire dame prend j'imagine
rb5 lendemain mange pas puis d'autres
qui garde ses pions et végétaux en d4
c'est à dire peut-être tour des quatre à
cinq et d'ahmed froid se mange pas de
pain et lampel b6 faille ils attaquent
flambée tu pouvais faire b 6 voilà tu
sais si c'est au moins le tour des six
et orale du bessin qu'un jour vous du à
cinq fables encore un et avec ton tpu en
épiant qui sont bloqués adieu fixer les
trois avec t2 et après faire tour des
six tours des 4 as pas de 3g qu'après tu
va t'attaquer à 3 bon ça c'est un
scénario rêvé oui c'est 6 à 5 tours des
six tours des cas tg4 scénario rêvé et
tu va t'attaquer au roi noir et comme tu
as la majorité pions sera soit forcément
plus faibles et tu seras mieux mais
c'est plus simple quatre chanceux tu
prends de ne pas faire de même si cela
fab peut-être bien d'un mal six tours et
huit tours 17 mai à 9,6 dom compris que
je pouvais faire pour des huit tours 8
mais je vais te faire tourner 1,17 après
je le faire d'un maître sith mbk tour
des huit tours 8 tours 1 17
ouais je pars du coup parmi les fuites
ne manque et utah qui fort de ses 4 6 4
peut-être
bon retour prend dans une tour et
prendre ses sept au caire à m pas dans
le délire c'est le coup j'aurais jamais
joué au foot c'est défend becs à une
vision structure va avoir des systèmes
de l'ong défunt 50 états d'âme la wii ça
permet de ramener les normes et je dis
pas que c'est mauvais c'est juste que
moi j'aurais pas vu ce coup quoi je
n'aurais pas pensé à ça et communautés
plus sûres du dernier du tour 17
directes at on vraiment prendre des jets
quai de loin peut-être g3 d'abord je
reçois monter le roi direct tour des
quatre
g
trois des quatre sympa impressionné
comme clément a tout compris entre
avocats s'arrête au ps il va te faire e
8 absolument qu'ils fassent dati conseil
comptait le faire tant des huit
victoires
bon ok on finit là c'est sûr guespin
alors comment savait l'herbe c'est ya un
petit quelque chose mais attendez le
tour et 8 on va devoir changer une tour
niveau as we bought a transmis v5 dans
des 84 tomber sept ans passe rien c'est
nul alors il va rester combien de temps
après cette partie va rester une partie
en fait de 5 plus sympa parce qu'il ya
cinq minutes et je pense pas que cette
finale après c'est possible qu'ils la
jouent pendant cinq minutes
si la joue vraiment à fond et qu'ils
réfléchissent et toi il reste quatre
minutes de tampon nul un peu moins mais
mais avec les secondes par coup bon en
fait vu quatre tours du thoré 8 change
un peu la donne
on sait que les lorrains comptent trois
compresseurs mais du culte est prévu que
la tv je vois pas comment ça tombe bien
pas trouvé des pins et savoir qu'on sait
que l'accès de tous à la whey donc ça va
ça se peut que ce soit la dernière
partie de de la cadence mais il y avait
qu à l'arrivée de la gare à l'étranger
trois pattes mais ok mais il va la jouer
des heures ya aucune raison de fermer le
gratuit non et puis tu es un peu mieux
si je dirais peut-être cinq nocifs et
qui le réserve pour plus tard mais ok
toi mais c'est ce genre de truc tu étais
déjà ça doit encore être nul mais tu es
quand même dans la zone dur à défendre à
tout cas magie n'aime pas je sais pas ce
que je pensais le faire quand même
qui mange que le 4 way bref quatre ans y
aller j'ai passé un été comme ça dans le
karst annulaire arrêt 2c truqué c'est
nul foutu paris dernière partie où ça
dure encore plus de trois minutes
ça dépend de guérir de ce qu'il a envie
de faire notre parti ou pas si vous
tournez vous attendez in the qui dit
qu'un super g m défense a facilement
défend oui facilement on ne bouge pas
par l'envié de son truc pas le problème
c'est que la tour on sait qu'à très peu
mieux classé des deux tours à 6 7 5
peut-être qu'ils passeront en h4 mais
bon servir à quelque chose moi il faut
faire tour des 4 as 4904 historique à 4h
faire et laisser cuire à coeur
par ailleurs on n'a pas trop d'idées au
procès marathon ces quatre banques et
quand on tente quelque chose quand même
là bas et enfin maman je suis à far west
de la bon je suis pour ma part qu'il y
aura trois tournées que joue h3k peut
être sympa mais pas moi j'aurais jamais
fait du bien et là j'aurai je te réjouis
cependant son pouce il le faudra voir
une lame est venu birex impossible vous
à venir d'intérêt bref deux et on va
faire tout racisme
il ya des gens on a fait un truc roger
job hockey / rouaroua g6 et maître f5
mitschek
tu vois pas faire rager 5 / à tour g7
dont geci suède heures voire six f-16 et
évangéliste et maintenant donc laurent
et c'est déjà quelque chose à manger
quatre virages qui est beaucoup en
commun
l'armée c'est un vrai quelque chose bah
oui mais c'est à dire acheter pas
chapelle sant cristau gagnant va faire
recette
puis toujours 8 août ou rue 6-7 tous
réussissent aussi mes tours 7e tour h
sur un tour à tour est vite peut-être un
ami un toit la fuite j'aime bien des
coûts en général fab pierre montet coups
sont bons les virois choisi de le battre
il va faire tourner oui au parent ou
alors il avait créé le violeur dessins
sont hiva et va y arriver c'est sûr ça
va être la dernière des cinq minutes 1
les cheikhs et chefs voit déjà des
milliards aux atours et du point de
saint cloud j'aurais pu planter au caire
il peut faire voir f3 remâche 1 h 4
ouais mais il y aura tout retour tours
4e
je pense qu'il a raté cinq années mes
bêtes auraient crié leur prendrait six
paires au quai numéro par rush quatre
ans bon pied bon oeil ce verdict ne
ménage pas trinquer non mais voocorder
h4 ça y est on est très énervé fable
comme ça je crois qu'il s'est converti à
faire en fait les barrages soient des
plantes ou 5 faire nul déception cinq
maintenant on fait toujours un échec
mais il a raté là mais ça c'est du guéry
tout craché c'est son défaut d'aller
nager bien bien bien dominé mais quel
nom âge 5 et 35 vaches combat il ya un
truc qu'on doit rater c'est pas possible
non mais là je comprends que tu peux
gagner mais moi saint martin sur au sein
qui fera torah 5 et bancaires
c'est le tentatives possibles
retrouvera quatre packs 6-4 c'est pas
pire que ça reste quand même comme
partie ce qui est dur c'est dommage je
bosse passent pas sur cinq maintenant en
fait lé tour des cinq pareil
ok mais attend bon on change pas trop ce
qu'on fait mon enfant ouais non mais
attends si je pense qu'on fait ça y est
c'est gagné incroyable bon c'est cool
bon voilà deltell plus proche mais
attends je vais essayer de regarder
sainte simone du projet la partie du
coup guy qu'il prend un gros lidin sa
life plc ma merde c'est boy
tu sais c'est comme au rugby quand tu je
sais pas tu a défendu devant ta ligne à
5 mètres a défendu défendu défendu
tu te rends laisser que tu voulais pas
prendre l'autre prend la pénalité ils
reprennent mais les tu défends comme un
fou et tu perds quoi bon et guiry +4
impressionnant lorsque l'on notre notre
cinq jeunes on est plein de cinq fables
mcphee la fema mais qui fait la gueule
ça quand je payais tour des singes
d'ailleurs il y anime zozos qui se fait
un peu qu'ils sont un peu chambrer dans
le chatt puisqu'il a écrit un super
j'aime défense a facilement et c'est
très dangereux très dangereux
malgré ces nouvelles questions et
comment il a perdu un peu c est mauvais
ce même ami qui a l'air un peu hagard
honnêtement il m'a l'air d'être des go
kg on le saurait ouais c'est difficile
difficile pour ma mai mais bon c'est pas
fait un fab ya mon élan mieux il ya
encore vraiment possibilité de revenir
dans ce match il ya que quatre points
d'écart alors évidemment ça paraît
beaucoup mais il suffit d'un petit rush
et il suffit qu'il arrive à moins deux
mois au final et c'est sûr que c'était
nul à tours et pendant longtemps et mais
bon il a fait craquer c'est bien je
deviens il faut faire donc le salon
cloud ouais ouais non non c'est cccc du
bo en fait ce que les autres tournées de
l'avis de tous les yeux tu voulais
ramener la tour en 18 alors attends je
vais mettre un petit mien si les gens
veulent des jeux juste aux toilettes
la longue on dit vas-y vas-y
je m'attends aussi bien si des gens
veulent va le partager sur facebook
[Musique]
donc j'ai mis un petit moins sur les
partager sur facebook et je vais faire
un petit tweet alors à faire le petit
tweet
[Applaudissements]
genre à faire mon petit tweet
je fais le petit tweet
ok de retour tu es de retour
voilà donc fab
ça va repartir de plus belle j'ai bien
longue nous avons une avance 4 bastien
quatre points de retard femmes way
oui mais là j'ai changé tu m'a rejoint
juste un an que tu as réussi rejoint le
côté obscur de la force
ouais je peux c'est sûr que ça c'est à
dire pendant la poste a rejoint le côté
obscur de la fosse quoi c'est un jeu de
mot fin du bon dieu utilise quand tu
vois ça je vois delpo je t'ai déjà dit
donnait déjà dit à quelques jours un
fable que dlp je le voyais en finale
voire plus sain je vois une finale delpo
djoko nishikori j'y crois pas face à
djoko perçoit pas moins soulevé la
nouvelle tombait g4 au match quoi parce
que jabron il rend pas vraiment hommage
non plus bas je sais pas un moment donné
tu dois tu dois faire quand même
alors ni que le chat marche pas alors
c'est les gens qui sont sur la chaîne
bitstream 10 le chat marche pas mais ils
comprennent pas trop le système de
switch
oui c'est la chaîne qui est aussitôt
monté sur le thé sur un autre chat en
fait n'a du coup faut aller sur le
douloureux je me suis pointé vhs com fr
oui vous avez cliqué pour aller
directement sur l'hébergement ou tu peux
rester dans le château blitzkrieg si tu
veux mais bon on va on peut pas suivre
tous les chats femmes c'est pas possible
non non non je vous avais tu veux que la
théorie
bah ouais tu peux tu peux tu étais sur
le chat busserine est tout à fait une
sorte de discorde bise
ouais bah tu peux tout le temps de
châtellerault tout le temps je peux tout
le temps est là donc
donc faut f5
il va attaquer c'est vrai j'ai quinze
années boum
elle a décidé d'envoyer un il a décidé
d'envoyer en jour at il dit on devrait
au sterenn on m'avait déjà hausse est en
fait la chaîne sur bitstream et je sais
pas il y avait beaucoup de monde pour
pour certains matches c'est dommage que
beaucoup de monde pour le match de
visites contre eux en fait le match est
le plus de monde entre guillemets sans
maxime c'est le match le plus ridicule
donc des fois je comprends pas trop en
fait
absolue la raison continue que les
algorithmes il joue beaucoup en fait sur
ces trucs là plus que la qualité du
contenu en lui-même si tu prends que un
intrus camps séparés quoi c'est un peu
dommage parce que ça dépend des horaires
ouais ça dépend de plein de choses il ya
peut-être la rentrée des classes j'en
sais rien en fait cette fois ça dépend
en fait je comprends jamais mais là
ouais mais beaucoup trop de temps 19
heures monsieur chinois manière n'a pu
non mais je sais pas je suis pas
vraiment de quoi de quoi ça dépend des
fois tu as été contenus qui sont plus
intéressantes à plus de monde et
d'effets autre point intéressant il ya
moins de monde c'est un peu comme ça bon
pas faire un si cela peut aussi dépendre
des des autres personnes qui strient
mais d autres contenus qui sont là les
visites c'est à 17h ouais mais peut-être
justement s'est retrouvée en première
page puisque c'est un moment il est
peut-être pas trop trop d'autres stream
intéressant même beaucoup plus
intéressant fortnight fab jetées à koto
cours en prime ben on refuse de boire
mais je sais que oui c'est plus
populaire que les échecs
malheureusement je veux bien être sport
be mythe
clash royal encore je comprends toujours
non reprendre de là je gagne je pense
c'est un peu dangereux
j'ai pas peut-être de l'esprit partout
non h5 just 4 u i way et en attendant le
sat peut-être juste tranquille os ou
d'objets 6e fois 5e 4 tape à 13h et
cazaux 4,3 attaqué plaisir de 4 ok ça me
premier coup une recul de sa marge
peut-être ça fonctionne je suis bien
dire à penser au concept étroit des
projets majeurs et de tourbe évitant
premier versement je veux me fait penser
que dépend de l'autre tour j'ai eu pas
mal mais c'est ce qui s'en sort ce que
vous pensez qu à se rassurer à jonathan
pinet dans prend tout je suis aussi ça
la fin ouais mais on va pas grand chose
on
miracle mais qu'est ce que j'ai fait
pour perdre non plus là et je pense
qu'il faut faire à prendre peut-être
intercalé c3 par contre peut-être faire
cavalier prend prisées ces trois comme
ça on garde le pion en vie mais
chroniqueur musical
pas faux si nokia c'est bien ça lui va
faire son camp peut aussi faire food et
2 essais 3 maintenant il est français
qu'à protéger à 14.7 vous les donne aux
kids
peut-être qu'il y avait un truc avec
fouet 3 je me disais il faut prendre 6
après dans certaines variantes à voir
mais au québec souffrent ces quatre fous
et 6
prise prise ok on a un peu la colonne en
sont aussi obligés d'accroître
rapidement
qui est tour 4 0
montour 8 et enfin je relaye il a une
façon cette île et surtout reste 4 il
peut faire tour deux tours machin et
tours 4 maintenant je sais il va gagner
le pion par lequel est roi je crois
c'était quand même ridicule
maintenant il ya souci tout reprend g4
menace pousser cette tour h3 made fable
mais c'est ridicule bafoue c'est cet
ouvrage prend le pouls de ce fait la
haye ok mais quand tu vas pas des trucs
que moi je vois tempo c'est grave quand
même même moi j'ai fait brûler il est
cagoulé fous ta cagoule fous ta cagoule
même à bas coût sur tout le monde sur
soi bakou
info trois dames des deux grands rock se
vend quoi
non ça va pas quoi oui on recommence et
des vues mais franchement on a un petit
ma mère mais déjà la sinne que fiscap il
n'était pas en toi moi ya de plus simple
ni mais bon il y avait une baisse de
régime qui réclame à nouveau un pardon à
bas coûts bas coût en dehors en trois
mots elle
donc faut être quatre dames dès 2 h 3 on
y peut être qu'ils revoient mais c'est
possible d'ailleurs ça mais c'est
vraiment plus qu'une prise j'ai pas aimé
leur d'abord pas fous seront trouvées
ses pieds ce serait pas mal qu'il fait
lui sont éloquentes il boit c'est 2780
et sony de quand il voit pas ses 2800
quelques noms mais je ne vois pas au
massage croire la pm oui à critiquer je
bois fois 2550
ouais alors h5 va trouver ce que j ai dû
faire une caisse de retraite h6 ne se
passe pas bien grave encore une fois peu
de biache 3 caillage tisser grand roque
le gange la chance là ça donne pas envie
de le recruter pour la prod chez sigma
mais non basse en fait c'est un hammam
et motivé de jouer trois ou quatre et
des pires que ça non mais hammam est
maudit évidemment tant il recruter mais
un mec flèche pour sky pro b 5e sa
menace en plus je suis à cinq épreuves
et 5 tu vas dévié et ta personne plus
qui pourra te parler quoi qui pourra
parler avec vous pouvez d'ailleurs il
n'empêche c'est un plaisir de jouer avec
les bleus voilà déjà plus tôt fait qui
inquiète je sais pas j'ai quatre raisons
tamada quelque peu comment peut-on
critiquer il veut faire bouger deux
peut-être et venir te prendre à revers
trailer de ces vers le bas et c'est
fantastique un honda horrible quand as
tu n'as rien développé ce qui est des 84
un poids qui écrire cinq blessés tu veux
parler des robes est passée par là c'est
comme le b à ba
comme il irait mieux rtas ces massacres
voilà un bras de fer aussi je regardais
quoi qu'est fait quoi ton vif
non mais pas germa mets et vins je sais
pas c'est qu'un grand flou d'être un des
trois études qu'amis et 3 et 7 4 ou 5
août you speak now khaimah mais peut pas
passer dans la boue comme ça je vous ai
chaque parent mais tu n'en fais pas ça
enfin et en partie ces 4 après le oui
non mais c'est quand même je sais pas tu
vas j'imagine pas j'ai pas envie de
critiquer non plus parce que j'aime
beaucoup ma mai
mais quand même mais non mais tu vois je
vois pas je vois pas écrit tout faire ça
je vois pas car yakine faire ça soit pas
cassée moubarak avec qui il a perdu
aussi donner des pièces mais ouais il
veut pas de votre dans les débuts non
mais géré par la queue
qu'est ce que le pain tu te rappelles de
la phrase de spa ce qui est de bonne foi
ok mais elle est importante cette phrase
quand même est-ce que tu as le droit
d'être champion du monde si tu te
permets de faire ça tu as que les échecs
vont te pardonner d'intel de l'afrique
non mais quelque part tu respectes pas
trop quand tu fais ça ok un service à la
cuillère tu peux mais tu peux pas cinq
ans de service avec l'air d'affilée
quand tu respectes pas le tennis danse
et enfin il est vrai c'est que le tennis
c'est un joueur de ce niveau là c'est un
peu étonnant on attend plus ça d'un
rapporte le dr claire un peu féconde
gris tchouk métrage attend plus ça d'un
jour de seconde zone
j'attends pas ça d'un mec qui est
candidat au titre mondial
l'épousé 6 je suis déçu son parti
gentiment su ouais parce que bon le
match promettait beaucoup bon il promet
toujours un corps d'un carnage cc2
l'attitude qui dérange
si on veut tenir juste ne vient pas je
fais un ne joue pas le match les
forfaits quoi tu es tu ne peux pas quoi
d'autre
non mais fisher fischer fischer c'est
différent tu peux pas comparer fischer
ces bugs d'affichage et pat uriné dessus
très clean mais bon c'est à aimer quand
ils jouent aux échecs joseph les échecs
il faisait chaud aux pieds les efforts
soient là tu vois il venait pas et de
merde il n'est pas messi était assis
devant un échiquier il avait joué pour
battre ça la fou prend et royal fille tu
penses nettement tour 8es il n'a jamais
fait des trucs comme ça fiche non mais
que moi je voulais à grob est tous assez
différent enfin moi j'ai aucune ambition
je fais une langue terre technique sous
vêtements différents
je suis dans une démarche différente
quand je vous ai fait moi
personnellement donc si je joue des
grappes ça dérange personne
non mais c'est sympa c'est que aussi
passé peut pas être un match exhibition
et à une vraie compétition est aussi
cité retraités ou des choses comme ça tu
peux pas non mais c'est comme si genre
tennis fait que des contres les gens ok
papa c'est marrant sur un plan 2d fois
t'as pas le choix c'est vrai tu reviens
sur loeb feront découvrir mais ça peut
faire naître une heure à chaque coup
quoi mais c'est quand même un manque de
respect pour l'organisateur il est
d'ailleurs du tournoi enfin gérard tu es
payé quand même tu as accepté de jouer
proprement ce peut-être faire un dessin
sur b4 qui est des cartes pour les
jouets cassés 6
matière parlons de sacs en plus on sent
bien les coups de plus facile de deviner
les coups quand le mec fait n'importe
quoi en face j'entends par là que la
différence de niveau entre guy et nous
elle se sent moins entre guillemets
quand on veut kevin et non mais ouais
c'est un manque de respect par rapport
au public par rapport aux femmes ok
c'est un peu fort de dire manque de
respect quand même mais on omet un mec
sympa pour moi j'aime bien le joueur
j'aime bien la photo des objets mais
comme dit joue j'étais content la
biennale de la danse en 20 pages est pas
une critique est bon d'indiquer mais
c'est vrai que c'est dommage de voir ça
il fait il sait bien jouer quoi il comme
le numéro 3 mondial et la 2820 un
histoire je crois que nous aurons
atteint 28 20 peut-être que 5 ou quoi
nam en fait on a dormi mais enfin c'est
aussi ça le truc c'est qu'on est plus ou
moins fan de son jeu et on a on aime
vraiment ce qui fait bien décevant en
fait mais on faire le cadet à trois
québécois mais je prends des tactiques
comme ça heureusement mais en fait je
suis plus moi quand je fais des huîtres
sur internet que mam ait là quoi
non mais qui aime bien châtie bien quoi
faire c'est juste qu'on ait beaucoup
d'espoir dans ce match là franchement
j'avais l'espoir de voir un gros combat
parce que geri lui répond présent et tu
sens que même un mam est à 100% c'est
pas sûr qu'il le batte un nom ce
précieux parce que gears il est chaud ce
soir ils mettent des systèmes existent
il est quand même pressing life info
faut pas minimiser la performance de
grille parce que même à ramer comme ça
faut aller le chercher quoi ediri ce
soir il impressionne famin alors là ils
peuvent petit coup de fouet gnafu prend
1,3 et fou fou prend 1 7e
mais je règle être des six quand même
mais bon tu va déranger sa tête on est
monté dans l'esprit m'avoir mais lui
doit pas
ces échecs mène largement en score il
est bien il doit pas qui se dérèglent
warfare le beau jeu même si ça marche ça
marche en pâtissent mais j'ai pas encore
vu le gamin je voyais pas plus loin
sympa le jury bien cette opposition est
gelé car ils étaient cinq à nous
demander qu'on vienne il réduite
peut-être content car tu es nul du coup
je suis je serai bien qu'il y ait des 5
je sais que ça ce sont les positions
c'est ce truc que je joue bien je sens
bien ces trucs là et dams et un après
suivant ce que tu fais
quel dessein qu'est ce que je peux pas
faire roigé cette dame s'est vite fait
d'être un fou des quatre ans car
désormais je fais un truc mais je crois
que j'ai pas téléchargé bon j'ai pas
j'ai pas téléchargé à partir bon moment
et contre eux pour autrui partie d'avant
le meurtre et marc utilisent-ils tony
malicieux 4 à 6 mais c'est une partie
fait faut pas comparer c'est ce qu'on
dit c'est un service à la cuillère et 10
service à la cuillère c'est différent 1
4 à 6 et une partie et se démarque en
syrie tout karpov a vaincu mais s'il est
perdu est parti personne en parle en
fait je m'en souviens parce que souvent
c'est bien tombé
c'est plutôt une gaffe de kart wii bonne
mais c'était c'était une partie il a pas
fait ou 4 à 6 à toutes les parties
d'affilée
mais ils héritent qui joue offensif est
de toute façon quand je leur dis alors
saguenéenne économique et d5 est ce que
ça marche est non et dessins qui dit
juste c'est prend des six nuls par
contre donc le choix c'est ce qu'il a
fait c'est pas malheureux éviter les
guider points de cette jeune province at
elle acquis des cinq viennent du cahier
des 5
c'est d'abord oasis qui vont chercher à
sa tête j'en vois pas l'écran femmes
donc c'était juste à titre informatif
pour nous quoi non pas cette position
gérance est égale un tu vas fouet fuite
et attendre moment je montre mon truc
ok c'est des petites potions de slaves
j'en ai joué d'emilie je déteste
toujours les jouets mairet faut cette
fois f6 marjorie si marrant parce que
jouer ça jamais aimé mais je joue pas
mal qu'on mais bon je préfère maintenant
on attend tranquille il faut rien faire
mais même ces 5 pourquoi les coûts
thématiques qui sont pas à jouer là pour
attendre mais il n'y a rien c'est juste
complètement égal surtout qu'il faut
faire gaffe cécile et blanc essayerait
de masse et leurs pièces allaient droit
mais tu peut contrer dans ces cas là tu
peux la gagner en fait aussi
ils peuvent pré pas pu te préparer des
petits trucs mais faut être méfiant avec
les blancs ce qu'après tu peux te rendre
tout d'un coup tour 17 retour des 8e
faire clouer par ces 5 et tu perds
tension quoi ça peut arriver aussi assez
bien ce qui fait guéri sodifis mois s'il
réussit à remettre son fonds g7 y aura
plus de problème et madame g7 là c'est
une grosse menace reste je fais d'alger
cette tour 17 tours des huit c5 ça va
arriver mais tu va carrément gagner le
pion je voudrais pas te donne le
déclassement non mais c'est peut-être
même mieux pour les noirs déjà je sais
pas à moins que le juste souhaité
changer ou pas mairie va faire tour 17
ans pour des sommes trop petits ça
fonctionne pour 17 ces forums bain
japonais mais ouais c'est ce que je
disais quand j'ai cette position ils
peuvent même tourné ces seuils de les
gagner avec les blancs ce qui a fait ma
mais c'est que mais tu vois là aussi une
facture c'est pas sérieux tu peux pas
dans cette position avec les blancs
après 4 couture trouvait foot fin
normalement cédée juste aurions c'est un
des cinq meilleurs genre d'histoire
l'europe reste sur mon visage il ya
peut-être une sais pas si limpide de
forme ou quoi mais on s'attend pas à ça
d'un autre joueur sait même pas
l'ouverture en fait qui va pas c'est
juste je sais pas c'est là depuis très
normé et après il a droit de patrons
former ou aussi deux matchs sur internet
parce que je sais pas si je suis
enceinte ou pas cet argument là je le
prends pas en compte femme parce que je
prends l'argument contumace sur internet
si tu joue à fond en fait mais là on
voit que tu joue pas à fond
donc ça veut dire maintenant les
impressions des joueurs et on a vu en
pro chelsea que même nos mecs étaient
pas forcément tout le temps des joueurs
a par exemple ma de cornette jouer tout
le temps à fond quand on est ok t'es
vraiment impressionnant et quand tu es
avec nous enfin est il a beau ne pas
être le jour le plus habitué sur
internet joue pas tout temps tout le
temps mais en fait en projet c'est qu'on
n'a pas dû
santi matures en dessous de son de son
niveau il a toujours été impressionnant
mathieu il a toujours 9es 1 je pense que
l'attitude joue plus que internet la
part belle au québec tu parles tu
toujours avoir un important bond de
connexion du fou appriou ce moment
d'ailleurs pascal adam en l'air de
l'autre côté on avance les noms ce
chantre pas mais je pense pas évident à
vivre pour ma mère patrie
conscient qu'il est pas fond est celle
là ça me déprime je pense de jeu mal
comme ça j'ai pas content de faire de la
merde
ouais et puis dire il a vu là je parle
d'être un teint non mais ça va revenir
il va s'asseoir
et ouais j'ai rasé les cheveux et jeux
sont partis aujourd'hui même nom mais
j'avais plus rien faire des cheveux un
jour j'avais des monfort s'est pas trop
en faire non
tu sens que dans la ma mort je vais
finir je faire découper la zidane piola
moi j'ai toujours dit alors est-ce que
même est ce que guy rivard raté une
place est possible pas trop comment une
faillite être bizarre là de nouveau et
comme d'hab en fait quand ça se passe
mal il établit prend vite des nuls quand
même ainsi cherche toujours fermée l'an
passé il avait joué aux échecs dames est
un échec
il est toujours là nul en poche s'il a
besoin vous pas m'attarder vite non
ouais j'suis trop vite selon jc pas mal
tomber cette tournée là non je suis
tombé huit c'est fort je pense à gagner
bien et peut faire dame des impôts
t'assure touré métro minutes ouais rien
voilà cet ours et 8
bon je pense qu'il a raté tour v808 rien
mes chiens non ça
il est l'oeuvre mais là c'est pas si ce
grade à mettre 500 mah mais qui a un peu
de un peu de réussite plein et c'est
tant mieux d'ailleurs
ça laisse à l'aise dans le match et je
pense que ton tour v8 gagner sur le
champ fab petite baisse de régime mais
tu vois ses larmes parce qu'on revoit
quand même les défauts des joueurs
aguerris qui est pas si tu erres quoi ça
mais c'est dur de gagner une partie même
gagnant s'est vu doter chaque jeu je
connais bien ce défaut si pour moi je
sais pas trop comment complètement
corrigé une façon assez chiant ce truc
il a fait l'aller kington jean guy qui a
déjà été fait contre magnus pour troller
laurent josée si je pouvais lui disais
sur le changement jette un oeil 7e oui
-13 lyrique qui vont dans un peu mais
bon faut toit ce qui est dommage là
encore c'est que ça n'est même pas à mme
amel envie de se dire ok j'ai eu deux
trois ouvertures tu as juste deux trois
trucs sérieux malgré tout est normal
data sont majoritaires il l'a pas fait
au début maintenant qu'il a menés de six
points c'est pas moi changepoint keeper
web soyons sérieux continue jacques
audiard qui s'est passé à la vuelta
aujourd'hui ce qu'on sait je ne sais pas
ce que je fais je ne suis pas la boîte
est attendu à ternay sa petite pause
pose portes à rodrigues donc comme père
rona s'est rendu à gagner l'étape
imagine surpris et meilleur grimpeur du
peloton un instant de rafale m mika et
dylan tonnes
je connais pas l'amour c'est quoi c'est
le classement général c'est irada qui en
tête il va toujours devant y est c'est
une 42e wind and i'm 50 veulent garder
le 54ème à lopez
venez voir il agrée gallopin qui est là
reste bas que celui qui est pour ma
bouche mais voilà voilà
c'était le point volta bonjour la tête
je vois des plus faibles ouais le roi
faible surtout mais faut réussir à
ramener le cavalier pas forcément si
simple fable fois c'est ce qui fait un
bon boulot vers le roi parents ils se
cachent 9 d'autres amoureusement ses 4
way défi 4,4 g 4 chat n'est pas là les
échecs népal est très intéressant je me
résous de mémoire sont des tigres contre
des moutons comme un fou et c'est un peu
la même pièce ou place poulain non tu as
que des tigres et que des moutons
qu'enfin tu fait il ya deux jours il se
jouera contre l'hôte à les tigres et
c'est de bouffer les moutons et vous
fait ça donnerait quoi
mais tout se complique ouais mais les
tic sont beaucoup plus forts ils peuvent
je vais bien je crois qu'ils sont que
deux quoi où ils sont deux ou quatre et
a beaucoup de moutons mais ok coiffer un
fou les vautours sont très nulle pa un
peu comme le jeu
cinquante mille pion entre chez plus qu
il faut que tous les pions way of france
s'appelle le chai de l'osbl ouais mais
enfin je trouve que c'est plus marrant
quand un des tigres
enfin tu peux faire tout le temps quand
tu te fais le chat de partout alors que
[Musique]
bon cette petite partie fab ma mère
il en a gagné combien de partis mais
jusque-là une gêne pas catherine là on
dit que c'est les tigres contre des
chèvres à 4 contre eux 20 possibles
je sais pas si l'info exact mais oui tu
peux faire une recherche wikipedia et
j'ai rien à refaire une série de vidéos
comme ça on joue avec l'achat avec h 3 e
gaming est la fameuse avec trois
voyagistes et j'en reviens pas si petite
série de vidéos un jour on joue aux
échecs un peu comme ça pas comment un
pas aux lieux ont pas les variantes les
matchs des trucs mais je cherchais pas
enfin un échec n'est pas les quoi dégage
quand on voit des décisions
ouais je sens qu puce titre après sur
les tigres je te laisse enfin fou on le
bat ouais enfin un match aller-retour
quoi et il compte les moutons les
chèvres
enfin les chefs de partout ce nouvel
échec ça peut bien sauter aussi enfin
foutu mais je pense que ma chère on
l'espère on passe de ton team
il avait la tête comme ça ne s'en fout
après comme l'autre faudra prouver le no
fake mais toujours très très important
le no fake la base vous pouvez le no
fake c'est bien avec mon frangin donnant
bien c'est dégueu tu perds l'option fin
pourquoi pas tomber de cette dame des
huit il veut te fouiner scott aura pas
d'échec côté calahan b2 et je crois que
j'avais une idée de fouine avec dams est
ménagé 5.5 guti va se battre en ligue en
se basant sur le vélo m'a mais le
sixième meilleur joueur de tous les
temps un peu exagéré mais c'est vrai que
c'est un énorme joueur la période ah oui
là marie van loan comme marcher sur le
tout c'est les vieilles expressions de
football manager enfin il marche sur
l'eau en fait un joueur et moi je
voudrais bien il est privé ça et là tu
as testé le nouveau nom qu'avec le
nouvel ordi tête on se voit une fois on
va vraiment se faire je conçois de
saison avec sainté on va être de partout
et cette wave plus de scream d'échec
c'est sainté de partout va en sortir à
les tifos têtu fait cavalier h4 lyssova
coelho 45 secondes contre 17
bon c'est foutu mène mon haletant
possible plaide un autre après je crois
que ma venue du jeune serbe mais qui a
jusqu'à demain tu prends en france et 7
pouces et 8 fois je crois je crois
n'existe peut faire [ __ ] ici surtout
si la wii mais si tu avais fait d'âmes
soeurs n'avaient pas le temps puisque
les foules et sept sur fou c'est sur
foot et sur foix iii manque un temps je
vous donnais bella faudrait une idée de
fouine mais bon
y at-il vraiment mémorable
ok mais c'est évidemment parce que c'est
si clair si tu veux être fort dam dom
ces raids a besoin pas mal il veut faire
dû cavaler f5 bac avec mention kiev 5 à
la chambre vous brosse nom d'un match 10
mâchoire damage six bombes sa tournée
grave s'il est gagnant est le roi et
boulot le bien il faut qu'ils jouent un
jeu passe c'est gagnant parce histoire
ça peut être gagnant n'a sûrement vers 5
h 5 et cambio tôt où la foule à ces
plantes pour le coup
d'autres options at il pas s'avancer le
mystique qui fait mal c'est pas trop mal
chez moi trop mal au final
mais bon qui aurait pu ajouter un petit
bleu bon ça va mais c'est dommage pour
m'amener puisque là encore je te dis nos
animateurs bin ouais je dis ok si tu
attends gagner une deux comme ça et que
quatre points d'écart est chez pas
peut-être en bullet sa stratégie du coup
elle l'appelle pénalise moins et il se
classe 6 démarrent les bulles est à -4
c'est pas pareil que moi 6 bah ouais
c'est pas la même chose
j'ai d'ailleurs trouvé le temps de trop
+2 il reste une demi heure
mc non donc c'est pour ça que j'y suis à
moins 5 pour une peinture et pourrait
rêver tournée - 4 - 3 est enfin là
encore il peut il peut encore rêver
tourné à - 4 - 3 si tu tournes à - 4 - 3
le match n'est pas fini un nom mais bon
faut pas qu'ils tournent à -6 sur s y
tourne à moins 6 tu as du mal à y croire
quoi il faut tourner à -4 fab mais bon
là encore ses positions insipide pas
insipide s'agit mais je veux dire c'est
pas c'est pas s pas grand avantage qu'il
a avec les blancs non solution c'est un
peu plus agréable il y avait peut-être
te faire l'essai des g4 g5
il a fort mal pris a rien
d'extraordinaire non mais l'énorme
falloir qu'ils jouent à l dame que nous
attaquent des minorités on en parlait
tout à l'heure en resterez dans ces
scènes ces huit baies quatre jours c'est
sa tour ses huit machin et
p4 il va envoyer en fait l'autre jour
quand on arrive à ce contact là
forcément greenplum chez moi je donne
cette attaque de minorité oui c'est que
tu crées zone de contact mais les blancs
ils sont trois en retard pour attaquer
le roi et c'est plus ou moins égale ça
non je pense je pense mais mais bon du
coup tu vois si ya pas trop attaque pour
les blancs puis non je comprends rien
mais à l'époque il te disais que c'était
mieux pour c'était mieux pour les pour
les noirs ça n'est pas pour le camp qui
avaient la taille d'une heure mais
maintenant on est moins bons dogmatique
maiwand matiko mais ouais c'est une
force après celui de maître du jeu blanc
en fait ils parlent pendant longtemps
des attaques de minorités et d'avoir son
père ça gagne tout seul
si tu lis un livre il pompe tonne partie
par exemple on fait ça ça va très bien
tu défends ce remake mais en fait 33
sicav fcp nouri bon et ses paroles
dessus comme d'hab les éléments qu'il
fallait évidemment mais bon ça va jouer
de l'om je l'aï vu quand j'étais petit
j'aime bien demain suspendu à damas six
encore plus fort est une inscription à 2
et se faire tour ses huit tours ces
trois matches ce week end et cette base
bien si on fait ensuite de faire tour
ces deux on va échanger et on fera damas
est la macif honnêtement je sais pas
quand je vois mal la guinée
ok c'est vrai que ça continue pas ça
tourne rondement bon livre pour la
française
attends je réfléchis je peux essayer de
moskalenko
je suis plus s'appelle the perfect
prennent toujours un nom comme ça dit
l'un d'eux mondorf le fera elle je pense
à un truc comme ça c'est pas mal c'est
pas hyper poussé théoriquement va donner
des idées des plans comme ça ah parce
que théorie théorie affronta les livres
de bergh cd gros pavé je vous rassure
tout à 1850 à mon avis how i what's on
ne les connaît pas les livres moi
j'avais dit ça qui saigne époque la
française voit la chine ont quitté pas
trop pressé que tu attends un peu et un
dvd que j'ai fais tu vas sortir de la
partie mais là il sortit en anglais et
il sortir en français les bons
d'ailleurs la norvège pas l'autre là
c'est parce que tu as le dvd que tu peux
passer les livres vous dire ça mais bon
c'était bien le format c'est peut être
ça et sinon livre peut-être douce câline
coup je recommande watts alors du coup
cette position ça va être un petit plus
pour les plantes meilleur sous noël
j'aime bien les blues face à lexington
c'est ça on doit tout le monde a peur
c'est surtout la one ever a écoulé 4 mai
le flexible faire tuer c'est pour celà
dit que la mini miss vous et 4 ça va
l'ong ighirri prend moins de risques et
mam et du coup mais je sais truc pourri
la nuit le dérange pas trop non plus
j'ai un son qu'on a un petit
enchaînement de nulle la balle quand on
mène au score
bastille grave
non mais il a révélé bon ouais mais bon
ça fait plaisir quelque part pour mam et
deux arrêtés un peu les mots radio ici
quoi parce que c'est vrai que c'était un
peu c'est un peu lourd mais en fait le
seul défaut que je vois c'est que t'as
pas le temps de souffler de temps m là
on en a porté le tournoi tu fais une
partie même si c'est en chan dix minutes
après tu as dix minutes ok tu peux les
marchés tu veux tapé dans un mur c'est
vraiment énervé d'une peine tout
envisages tu fais ce que tu veux quand
tu pars avec un pote tu fumes cia
étaient fumeurs à hockey de plein art
mais là non la tête tu joues tu veux du
jour et que tu bouffes quoi été débouté
ouais c'est ça mériterait peut-être
toutes les demi-heures d'avoir cinq
minutes de pause ou une minute après
chaque partie je sais pas même ça
surtout veulent comprendre d'après
hurler ce top 20 du relais je sais pas
n'importe quoi mais en plus c'est dans
tous les sports comme ça va vous pouvez
on parle souvent du tennis - tennis
pareil tu veux de jeu tu tu souffles
avec toi tu vas te la forme c'est pas
que physique en fait on se pose en fait
permet de souffler de problème je
pensais que quelqu'un connait tous
rejoindre un beau cadre naturel du truc
en allemagne des fois pour ça je
retrouve ce site est un non non non ça
certains d'une part je cherche ça est ce
que c'est un petit plus pour les noirs
fabu c'est juste nul très facile pour un
top chrono
un petit troll guillemets mais ça passe
le rythme des retransmissions moi j'aime
bien comme ça à aux jambes et aux fesses
je comprends à l'intérieur du jeu veut
dire en tant que compétiteur je vois le
le côté qui est le petit truc chiant
il ya même grand chose a approché l'an
dernier quand je le samedi après midi là
ouais c'est vrai
franchement c'est chiant faute mais moi
qui ai mis un blitz et et où j'en avais
marre ans qui veut il veut pas tenté
tour des 5 ou quoi ok encore nul voila
qu'est ce qui se passe en cette
ouverture fab f4 a enfin voilà petit bug
masquer les jouets great chauvière
controverse les sauts voilà quatre au
moins bon ça c'est mieux que c'est mieux
que kadhafi ce qui évite ce genre de
chose quand même
moi je trouve pas le monde mon tournoi
je suis honnête à mon tour match n'est
jamais loin derrière mais on m'a dit que
c'était pas mal mais cherche tous les
tournois vers la suisse et allemagne
ou alors tu peux tenter des trucs europe
du nord membre la positionne cas
pourquoi pas ce dépend du niveau aussi
femme oui maintenant il cherchait un
truc naturel du respire tu souffres donc
des forêts des choses comme ça après
même en france si jamais tu aimes bien
tout ça tu peux faire oui à villard de
lans c'est joli site web où tu étais
complètement la montagne totale là où
j'étais très haut en altitude il n'y a
pas grand chose je pense y être 200
personnes en village mais vont
clairement dans les montagnes je vais
être contre cette europe forte
non mais c'est attendra sans prétention
on va dire que les annonces mais juge de
dire si si tu as envie de te balader
tout ça s'écoute frais être sa part du
président c'est pas faux retour noir ça
est-ce qu'on fait lord anne decis tour
des huit on s'organise vers le pion des
sais pas ouais charmant parce que tous
sont venus des trois sections art est
donc très content d'aller mettre la
potion dessus je pense dumb & sisters du
québec qui sait si c'est un plan
intéressant pour aller viser la case la
case des 4 b 4 ça le bc je sais pas
j'aurais pas fait sauf si elles brazon
pas si tu veux toujours qu'elle est bien
qu'ils aient des deux pays je sentais
que j'allais faire ça car derrière
malgré ma 6 oui mais ça l'a questionné
le pic des millions de vies comme
tournoi beaucoup de soin j'ai jamais
fait mais voilà par exemple des trucks
et aime bien la montagne ça peut être
cool aussi
ces sept ans et six femmes 1 mais du
coup c'est une présentation
j'en arrive à faire un film c'est
désormais trois affaires qui avait eu
quatre quais à laissac adam qui les
français souhaitent que j'aime bien mais
on prend il fera tout en france et 5
juin mais du coup non mais ma mais j'ai
vraiment pas en forme ce soir face à
alain delmas et au delà des ouvertures
nuit là le surnom message ou en fait si
tu fais tu commence mal en profitant un
peu juteuse leurs joueurs à la con tu
penses à perth mauvaise humeur et ipad
mais ton meilleur impact in réduire
passé avec 4,5 et spinales ouvert la
porte et l'espagnol qui joue très bien
c'est un très bon joueur de de 4,5
depuis qu'il est petit jude et petrov du
machin sartoux rien cette petite vente
avec dams dont tu parlais tout à l'heure
très bien fallait pas moins bien réseau
autour d un c4 marc alain ce truc j'ai
pu faire c'est des cages mais ça existe
en effet pas pris pied jeune fille
alizée surprend f3 d'emprunt f3 qui il
ya deux ans déjà quatre états d'âme
projet tf1 non mais il faut que ce soit
autour des déchets
à 8h08 échec aussi et là du coup ans
qu'elle s'est fait faire du québec a des
trucs comme ça quoi jacqueline des
doutes mais pas sans ses traces à quoi
bah c'est sûr qu'il ait fait un cahier
des 4p 4 mai à temps c'est juste
concrètement est ce que tu fais en fait
un réseau d'été je n'ai cessé ses salons
du parler vrai ça a été joué un truc
c'est concrètement tu avais pas de coups
avec les mains donc aimer avec demain
c'est plutôt dame e3 le cours du jeu
checkez la base compliqué hein comme
position depuis damas il joue et qui est
des 4 s'élargît couet coup j'ai cinq ans
puis une partie de la prime but comme
plaire en bleu quatre l'étaient bien que
noir là bas on devise c'est jouable mais
[Musique]
l'effort est qu'il faudrait qu'ils
aillent à une salle à moins 7
allez faut que l'on gagne de la manne et
qui reviennent qui reviennent à -5 avant
les bulles est pour pour se permettre d'
un peu rêver en bullet y avoir une
dizaine de partis c'est simple il va y
avoir une dizaine de partis donc
[Musique]
tant qu'il peut il peut revenir quoi je
suis à nice chaussures mandat mandat je
sais pas peut-être il a bossé pour lui
n'est pas contre mais maintenant c'est
moi un mois s'explique et plus fort
ouais mais déjà est né au kenya plus
d'ambition que même il ya cinq ans dès 5
ans était encore candidat au titre
mondial et je compte 40 chaînes l'avant
en fin de cycle quoi ils font encore des
tournois il est pas ridicule c'est déjà
super 30 à 50 ans mais qui rythme allait
mobiliser son énergie pour pour ça aussi
stocker brute tombe en ruine mais je
pense à juste kelly prend 4 et sur
lequel les français et françaises
bah ouais mais bon toute attente et
d'amman non je pense qu'il est bien que
l'ancien fait d'être là en nombre des
trucs c'est très compliqué bien sûr
parce que peut-être quand même vous
réussi cinq ou dix ans puis on pressent
à trois problèmes sattouf m6 tient peu
les cases de pène idiot comme une
décision alors qu'il pensait de vaucluse
j'ai même pas regardé mais claude pointe
ça tu n'étais pas là c'est pas ça je
serais pas là dedans mais juste parce
que bon j'avais besoin de calculer ça me
semble un peu ça du gauche sous la toile
bon alors attends on a quand même deux
pièces une tour on est pas mal bon ça
doit toujours quand même sympa prénommé
sept camions pour les morts activité au
final il suffit juste de passer un peu à
un moment difficile et ça va aller mal
m'en faut le passer
50 secondes need you man qui fait qu'on
ait des cas tellement ce que j'avais vu
aussi ré est là depuis un passé je ne
peux comprendre qu'à huit matches donc
et pas mal je vais d'un point de vue
pratique de pas prendre la tour de fer
dame c4 ouais tu regarde un peu ce que
tu tout autour du roi alphonse xiii plus
que deux pièces a donc peut-être
qualifié 5 kg 5 cd réussi ce matin ma
vie je vous dis coup il perd 3,8 ou un
truc c'est bien joué un rituel inscrire
avec les blancs jeu profond on sait peu
de fer tourer ça va gagner ça pour ma
part ça fait plaisir pour ma mais ça
leur lance un petit peu quoi parce que
c'est davantage une ouverture il faut 4
5 2 par michel-ange évident
non mais c'est la différence basse il ya
pas que ça évidemment mais bon si tu
pars pas je constate partis d'opposition
dégueulasse c'est plus dur à remonter
que d'autres mais c'est sûr dans la
position est correct était correct et il
a bien joué la gagne et il s'est pas
laissée arnaquer non c'est cool alors on
est reparti non mais là c'est une
demande normale deux des cadres et ceux
bellagra toutes les gagner mais ok voir
des échecs et me disait qu'il ait changé
d'avis là tout d'un coup sans
sans qu'on sache vraiment pourquoi en
fait d'un bouquet de 12,4 c'était la
partie de la paire par tom cette boisson
en vain au gps suffit je ne peux pas
faire sa part en plus il s'est enfin il
faut remonter et ne pas perdre le match
mais enfin watts un bel exploit
ouais mais c'est possible - déclarait
mais tout est possible si ce match était
gagné à dire si gagner encore celle-là
qui repasse à -5 il reste encore une
intrants puissants qu'ils la gagnent
encore qui va vers ça est longue et
rivas 90 bintou nettement mais on sait
pas
bahar mais des fois ce phénomène là deux
des vases communicants d'un ballet si tu
commence à fatiguer c'est pas le mec
recommence à bien jouer il prend
confiance il veut que de la merde en
deux heures et trois victoires ont
conclu non
j'essaie de vendre un peu de rêve aux
ingénieurs puissant l'akwaba oui
j'essaie de vendre du rêve
voilà du coup cette position bon ça
oscille entre à polluer pour les blancs
égal je dirais un peu d'humour les
blancs brève allocution à 7 qui est
complètement fixé par la dame à la tour
là qui arrive colonne b c'est richard
entré jettent sur les idées ont baissé à
c'est bien c'est bien c'est en train de
prendre forme en et ça peut être
déstabilisant pour guérir une grande
stratégie en nouveauté dans la proche du
speech est sûr est que je de la mère de
madame
et tout d'un coup à plat ben tu t'y
attendais pas en fait je sais jouer est
latent peu plus quoi je craque
totalement mais n'avait pas trouvé cet
emprunt a tué un homme déçu c'est faire
laminer 6 à damas est photographe
bon bah tu faire peut-être que cinq
aussi non non non moi je joue sur le
j'ai toujours pas tout à fait le même
ce projet est désormais wars ajouté
mathieu justafré russie va pas du tout
alors qu'est et -5 fab
ouais ok mais la stratégie est juste
machiavélique
si c'est vrai c'est comme stratégie en
fait je ne suis que de la merde
[Rires]
normalement il est loin d'un organisme
qui croît moins cinq cas -8 et quand il
jouait je crois et je voulais vraie
partie d'échecs
il met des purs au centre et sur ces
pièces ne sais pas quoi maintenant 20
coups avec laurent 8 et justes a damé à
québec et langer 4h schiste le truc
c'est que si on gagne ça la c4
enfin allianz et 4 points à faire ces
nappes 800 personnels qui vont aussi le
côté psychologique que tu fais que de la
merde on ne sait pas quoi
non mais ça va pas être évident à gérer
pour dirinon flux non monsieur
après avant tu vas tu leur as dit avant
le match après une heure et demie de jeu
ou 2 1 michel jutras sera plus 4 même
durant la très content oui mais bon
mais oui je vois déjà une demi heure
avec vos mots justes 12 oui j'aimerais
fille à un moment où on a tous cru
qu'ils nous sortent une tactique du
futur a fait c'était de la merde ça
génial et c'est beau quelque part c'est
beau voilà ils seront à cette attaque
des minorités la même foi de 8 heures
c'était des couleurs à verser non tout à
l'heure face tct guéri qui lancent des
couleurs inversées savait que la dre
ouais alors tu fais ce que tu en vois
ces cas tu le purin isoler ces quatre
longueurs à ses comptes
moi je voyais ces quatre silhouettes
clair - les autres c4 et c5 jours c'est
satan sont envolés comme la vuelta c'est
gervais tout est comme la vuelta
ils s'envolent au québec 3 il se dirige
vers ses cinq ce couloir kébé 4ème qu'il
prend à 5 tours 8
possible
oui mais on doit pas être mal mais qui
la lie à eelv à rebrousse poil faire kf5
et va t'envoyer tout sur le roi
peut-être dams et quatre cavaliers f5
les bas-fonds et quel saint nous vouer
ça donne des coûts d'emprunt 4 paraît
logique après le carnage cinq est bien
bloqué par du g4 à un moment donné
pourtant fermé ok 124 j'aime bien un jeu
statique mais ce que c'est efficace
voilà ça c'est autre chose est sûre g4
avec les f4 pour le moment mais vous
faire surveiller 4 comme le lait sur le
feu
ce cas tout moment ça peut quand est ce
que tu peux confirmer
enfin c'est de la dernière partie trois
minutes un jeu alors que le chômage est
à part cadence s'il vous plaît bah je
sais pas le score exact c'est qu'il ya
cinq ans pour guy actuellement 12 à nice
et je peux éventuellement tu récupères
et ça
voilà je te dirais que la vie de quatre
points dans le 5 et de l'ipad
je peux mettre à l'écran je touche
française en matant faut juste que je
fasse un petit réglage et je vais
pouvoir vous mettre le le score total
par cadence si m'hamed grine le match
sera à remettre de l'histoire de chaque
baguette motors a quand même pas
forcément mais ok je vois campe hedwidge
je veux dire le retard à tuer ils disent
qu'un bel et bien donc à mon bel effort
il ya 6 et nuit deux ennemis en 5 + 1 il
ya que si 53 + 1 là bas c'est ce que je
disais alors plus qu'à très puissant il
ya pas j'ai quatre là quand même qui
sans ces marchés finalement la tête tour
à 3 voire 4 à 4 6 1 il reviendrait
basque et si j'oublie ok donc donc mon
agence est des fous des 6 un petit coup
comme ça tu défends trou et j'ai bien
une guérilla il est même très bien et
aussi mais manqué juge
la sauver le pion du roi il fait j'aime
bien bien peuvent criminels qui est très
dangereux écrit mme notre raison de
faire caillou 5tourcoing six tours
achètent leur âge cette paix et cette
fuite mat
ouais mais pourront adapter à tour aussi
soit si la mannschaft est donc et j'irai
pour qu'elle s'ajuste content d'un
restaurant tu as bien peu dans mes
veines du cou faisant de données la
qualité de ses parts à lui en le truc de
qualité ce qui est quatre bars et
qu'elle prendrait six je sais pas c'est
génial c'est un nouveau pas en fait si
la perle fini où il ya quand même quatre
en l'air va c'est pas fini mais oui ça
c'était génial
je prends les sticks les mécanismes à
priape appréhendé sept chez pas mais bon
oui oui il aurait juste pu prendre à la
tour en fait je pense ça pas si simple
ça peut être six ans et lorsqu'il
apparut la droite attaquant mais c'est
sûr qu'il peut pas laisser une tour en 1
coupe qu'elle a il ya un petit coup de
mou pour les 2 1 pas plus pour guérir
ouais parce que la période est besoin
complètement gagnante
au pire tu rates été fait nulle part ça
s complètement finie la wii il à perdre
ok mais fab jusque 4 jusqu'à troqué on y
est
écoutons ok il a résisté en trois plus
un mais la brouille est de ce point de
mauvaise série mais mais mais lloris est
décidé à jouer aux échecs
après ambühl ati de notre fait rage
trois cibles ne sera pas regardants vue
lettres seule chose mais bon tu vas
boire de plus tôt non mais je pense que
le match ait une fois d'être est loin
d'être terminée et femmes
le match est loin d'être terminée à mon
avis passe pas du 50-50 mais tu as et 80
je pense que c'est un 80 20 je pense que
c'est pas ta fille passant à 0
c'est passant à 0 c'est du 80/20 et
c'est pas et sait pas et c'est pas
évident pour un guiry de gérer parce que
le le scénario est cruel fin cruelle
en gros ils dominent devine domine
dominé un truc c'est qu'en plus ils
perdent et partout il est bien tu es
commence à se faire arnaquer et n'oublie
pas que c'est arrivé hier à kariat qui
n'est au final il a perdu la cession de
la séquence de bullet de trois points je
crois donc il veut faire avoir les nerfs
très solides même parce que la petite
est clair l'écart n'est pas normalement
les ja mvele tuvalu d'autres au stade
quoi new york et pour l' us open ouais
aujourd'hui ils allaient suivre sans
direct ne sous ses yeux
il est 16h améliore pas tout à fait
15h42 ça va commencer dans 20 minutes
normalement sur axa pourrait après je
crois que c'est commence un tout petit
peu enfin c'est les échauffements quoi
mais ça a plutôt commencé à 15 23h15
suspense 22h15 pardon non mais ça va
être beau ouais ça va être un beau match
il y en a combien de temps de machin de
30 minutes ça s'ajuste tu vas pouvoir
enchaîner
tu vas pouvoir enchaîner les deux en
fait
bon fab est toujours pour guité pour mam
était pour qui on sait plus bon je te de
retirer de ce match mais bon
certainement car tout le monde comme ça
moi j'ai quand même espoir qui est qu'
un petit retournement quoi attirer j'ai
envie de vivre un petit frisson j'ai
envie de voir une égalisation j'ai envie
de voir des prolongations
non mais bon en question mais bon
j'aurais par tennis aussi plomb pas trop
de pression aujourd'hui
en fait tu t'en fous de rater un jeu non
ok c'était très important
tu a duré quatre heures et demi ou cinq
heures là ce soir
le magicien être celui-là sûr il va
vraiment être très loin bah c'est pas
sur un nadal l'a vu sur 13 ans mère
d'une fille d'aujourd'hui ils vont
paraître presque faire en trois sets
mais je sais pas mon toutou possible
83,7 aussi lui va affirmer tu as raté un
jeu enfin si tu as rien rater en fait
qu'en plus ce match tu peux enfin et
c'est obligatoire qui dure ça peut pas
être un match en trois sets c'est pas
possible
oui je peux vraiment sata du rap à 20
minutes le match sans fin au moins pour
deux heures et demie puis j'applique et
j'espère note
mais comment dire pas vraiment un vrai
kit est ce qu'il ya un match qui oppose
pitch est dure longtemps préfère que ce
soit pas très longtemps les jours les
machins ça dure pas très longtemps les
le fait c'est une de 5 une de 5000 1 et
une de 1 plus 1 en fait d'une 2,5 pouces
un une deux 5 + 1 parlant une deux trois
plus à une impression
en tout cas c'est parti à fond la caisse
bouille avait pu arracher son parti mam
est très chaud connu voilà ça va
forcément envoyé fin comme dans la
drogue
tous les fondations du classique c'est
si le rox de la méritait de foot ranger
6,7 notre tour j'ai alors attends au
niveau ils sont combien en bullet guiry
et à plus de vélo mais du manic mamie
joue pas trop donc ça avant mais il ça
veut rien dire surtout que c'est du un
plus un donc c'est différent du 1 + 0
quand même et il m'a mais doit être un
bon joueur de bullet j'ai du mal à
imaginer qu'il ya un gros écart entre
les deux qui étais tu viens îles tonga
val torah tu te crois qu'un bon cavale
de te prenais envers hexis c'est sûr
mais est ce que vient faire beaucoup en
effet six à dix après so what
sans qu'il ait mûri clés noires femmes
s'ils peuvent se faire tour et froide
f53 bon pendant une qualité je pense
qu'on a conclu je vais te dire où
at-elle c'est parce que là bas mais tu
vas faire sa femme s'était pas le choix
juste c'est parce que seul à bord
enfin quoi ils envoient les pions ou
méfiance saverne quoi chaque coup de
pouce des pions que c'est à trouver du
contrôle de ma mère ouvrir la grande et
belle fête accès d'option sera vidée et
du cou ainsi la menace d'amendés 4 ans
et 3
c'est pas les ménines certitude pour
dessein christianisme faut qu'il fasse
gaffe guy risque sur la huitième et a
plus personne
il peut se faire si on prend comme
prendre un projet mis un fab de dunham
damas 7 4 la mairie fait des clashs
quatre courts châtains mais sacrément gc
s'est produit à tout prendre on est à
vingt secondes quand même pour la tenure
mais bon ok ok je ne sais pas fini même
ça tu as changé d'âme mais bon tu auras
toujours très faibles donc et une tour
tokyo qu'il a assez bien joué ça ça
s'est assez bien vu ça de la part dieu
guérit pas surprenant qu'ils feignent à
guy qui il a eu chaud à l'ayraultport
ans j'habite je suis beaucoup plus
souple pour le bullet que pour les
autres qu'à lens à l'étoile à problèmes
de connexion pour guérir je peux le
petit truc rouge mais ouais ça peut
jouer face à valence sa connexion est
revenu mais si sa connexion est mauvaise
pour les bullet ça peut coûter cher
femme orientale plus un mais bon après
aucun des deux n'est ne saisit donc
avantageux bah ouais
et qui renvoie la raison vient d'enrôler
tu vas s'il était revenu à moins 3
c'était pas la même
le chronomètre n'est pas parti je vais
faire partir le chrono tour trois balles
je l'écouterai dans votre juste il
envoie sa partition pas sa surface après
six adultes assurer cette partie comme
en défense pour des 1 3 car ici sont
fous dégage ça résiste pour le vent
quand même côté man est un malade
position qui pariaient chaude à défendre
puisque compromise
il a réussi à rester en vie mais il ya
celle ci cela et b2i bouche tout d'un
vrai pac man called maquiller la chic
chocs cool gallia-théâtre gamme angèle
un domaine dans lequel vous fait trois
pions d'un coup quoi je pense que les
gagnants les chevaux la cavalerie
arrivés des quatre cinq ps trois échecs
mais il a raté plus facile à voir quand
tu commandes dans les bulles de cet acte
i mais bon on fait là ils jouent à toute
blinde je sais comme quoi il ya trente
secondes enfin presque il ya des trois
est ailleurs il a raté gain facile et
changeante jour gagnant mais bon c'est
beaucoup et tout peut se passer là je ne
veux en rien en fait froid c'est
tellement évident pas à dire s'il avait
réfléchi
non mais ya pas d un trip hop il a 40
secondes et c'est tellement dommage
ouais là maintenant avant
peut-être l'organisme a brui banuls sexe
mernier wifi pas nul le site baril et
blanc peuvent y est né oui si tu vas pas
faire mieux
non mais c'est grave parce qu'elle est
roi bacquet pas que permet même il ya
ceux qui a qualité quand il n'est pas
besoin d'un match 5 et b5
non c'était pas s'appliquer les actus
arriver là c'est dommage parce que ça
pourrait être jusqu'à 30 plus cher mais
en fait il y aurait pu être plus à 2 l'a
déjà ce qui a pu gagner celle qu'il a
perdue donc ça aurait été vendu 2 5 3 il
aurait pu gagner grâce à ses fins il
pourrait y avoir deux points d'écart
l'an fait déjà ouais mais bon époux qui
ajoute une ford ka ba élevés vont enfin
les réalités gaiement les deux fois h4
laisse évidemment écoute pas gagnant bah
si c'est bien dans les duels et el assad
avant lui il ya deux noms mais bon il y
aurait pu être si celle d'avant était
gagnant mais n'avait pas rendu
oui oui non mais bon j'ai des parties
animées quoi voir ses collègues à
recevoir des pions triplé mais ça va
conduire au mieux ces possède beaucoup
turin s'est parfois à l'écart est
magique oui
[Musique]
suite à mach 3 eme mais alizé qui ne
rentraient pas d'inscrire concept
moyenâgeux j'adore j'adore ce carré au
mieux en fait il se fait taper aussi
c'est marrant comme carré des bases plus
solides que les autres en plus d'une
importante mais avait dix a pas d'enjeu
ce cas rien du stim intrigue
il plaque
il est pas très mobile quoi c'est juste
un quart et un gros carré pour mieux ne
pas y aller c'est pareil que le roi vert
à 2
et puis l'autre
heureusement on se fout et trois à
pouvoir bouger d'ailleurs le nahd un
cassage de carrés et tout le roi se
battre par tous c'est génial j'adore la
partie de l'équipe i heard you may take
down joue commenté qu'on peut que
l'admirer cette oeuvre d'art par titre
ordinaire c'est bon il restait un
triangle blanc du caricom à partir de
tiger est tout sourire une île mais je
pense que nous faisons des six du
cadavre on n'y a plus rien le car est
mort c'est fini la partie et faire des
films il abandonne pas mais bon tu vas
enfin petit pirc
taëf et la mieux celle la rame les
jouets que l'option raciste j'ai pas
mais revient enfin si gagner celle-là tu
reviens à 3 après tu reviens à deux je
sais pas à quoi était été apprêté
ex-aequo le plan assez simple tous
viennent y aller rock des quatre
captures le cadre guy m'a pas l'air ou
flats avons oublié ou 4 c'est bizarre
qu'il craque sous les coups de boutoir
quoi infléchir
non c'est pas mal de son calibre 6 aller
vers le haut 6e fois en six mois mais ça
fait partie du morceau 6 au 11 juin
waouh
qu'est ce que c'est et si ces quatre qui
peut arriver que ces 6 g pendant qu'elle
résume un trio 200 ok f7 il refait une
partie du laonnois troupe de six mois
c'est à dire est que l'on est tous très
contents fuit pas les échecs de merde ça
il se passe des choses pour tout casser
les c est extraordinaire
quant à sa tessiture pas clair deuxième
détenu pour les blancs sont à quatre où
ils peuvent apprendre nul là on voit
quatre
merci d'envoyer la mamie qui joue mais
qui jouait
g45 et je suis à paraître froid etc et
des docks à l'épreuve trois mamans qui
soit pas le sable
c'est bien pour les blancs non que je
sais pas j'ai toujours l'espoir d'éviter
à tour ni décédera qu'il dernier pion
qui faisait
et c'est 4 super trofeo qui se tiendra à
la tour allait bien pour lutter contre
les deux pièces mine à cause de jantes
finale elle se bat bien mon niveau de
jeu et de détruire beaucoup plus forte
de l'an en finale non final la tour elle
se bat à fond ouais bon touriste en
fonction c'est élémentaire mettre son
calice devant le pion n'importe quelle
case michel-ange et sea hawk est nul
mais notre but en 16 minutes
seize minutes ça fait à peu près fabre
400 partis c'est un parti sur comment ça
non et mamies qui pourra peut-être
regretter finalement ainsi perdre le
match
banier il va en fait il a trop laissé
filer amour c'est à dire alors cette
position enfin ça s'anime de nouveau en
tout cas ça aurait été le plus grand
essai le match alors on a eu le moins de
temps parce que j'ai vu seulement tu es
moins de gens qui auront regardé alors
si c'est le match le plus intéressant de
tout le truc est alors il me renvoie à
un moment on était déprimé comme il est
séché le score aisé que de la merde mais
devant les réactions
le match le plus sympa en tout cas au
niveau de défunts à ces matches c'est le
plus envoyer en fait c'est vraiment
voyez il ya personne qui a fermé le jeu
se déroule pas sur les mener jusqu'au
bout qui prend 5
quoi
je suis pas genre semble qu'il envoie
vraiment tout et n'importe quoi est
fantastique ouais mais ça c foot je
t'aime coup en fait faux vis cam sait
déjà c'est pas ko invasive non mais je
fais des facéties et berlin paquet sur
internet j'ai fait j'ai une fois je
pense j'ai perdu un titre à cause de ça
dans les départage
c'était ce type parti de merde en
rajoutant les stands 2001 tu vois je
t'ai pas me tue à l'époque pour moi un
médecin blitz a ajouté mme booba a joui
permet un jeu de massacre et je suis
beaucoup mieux voir gagnant puis ok y'a
plus que je pas j'en fasse bon je suis
un bagage quoi pour l'autre et moi j'ai
encore trois minutes et je sais qu'ils
aiment à charleroi et chipa il s'en sort
et jacques pas guéri et après je tombe
dans fouquet contre roy et je me suis
même si la rage ou de temps mais le
pendant à de merde alors que je me
concentrais un peu de jeu tempo n'avait
pas d'âme c'est évident français cinq là
je crois que si on dirait il a vu après
il a raté une fois il a vu au coup
d'après mais oui bon ça va faire du
moins trois tout ça quoi et b6 jusqu'au
bout un peu la pendule tu joues bas le
temps il met le temps à deux ans mais
c'est logique
ok mais il joue le temps mais ils jouent
pas à salles comme avait fait gris chaud
qu'une fois serre qui l'attend pas les
30 secondes ou jusqu'au bout tempo quoi
j'apparais que pour moi c'est pas ça va
on va dire qu'il est dans la limite des
trucs qui sont the way faisable gens
vont dire ça reste dans l'esprit quoi tu
les pois fond tu veux tu être du tout m
pauthe a tenté un patelin ok tu peux
kessas a rejoint twitter il n'avait pas
pris cinq fois que c'est une des toutes
premières parties du matin la première
il est gardé au débat théorique pour le
budget c'est accor -3 1 il reste combien
de temps je viens de dire ça il te reste
douze minutes le chef du truc
en fait ça va assez vite quand même
n'est pas qu'elle prend kg 6 mchale 6
highgy qui est quand même en train de
madame branche la fab
tu le sens le frisson à mal et n'y a pas
mal comment vivre à fond de court ouais
c'est pas con vivre là c'est que enfin
tout est possible la femme soit dix
minutes
fab il reste il reste onze minutes la
seconde minute
ok non honnêtement tout et tout est
possible enfin c'est je me demande même
si guy est pas en train juste de
complètement craquer si si c'est pas
déjà du 50-50 cette histoire parce que
aucun ou
[Musique]
vous ma mère ou ma mère en porterez
c'est la moins un en remontant comme sa
femme en mode remonte à da en mode tu
vois tout serait possible serait fou un
faux pas qui personne même pas la peine
de faire mais nu c'est pas grave ma nul
je garde la droite on avance jugèrent
battu cher ce que tu peux gérer mais là
bon cédric nuls comme la potion de quoi
je veux dire pour mam est nul c'est pas
grave car il reste à moins de il reste
encore des parties à sa porte dans ces
tirs par contre une défaite ce n'est pas
complètement fini mais ça ferait mal
mais il est bien ma mère est la leur
dans le ruck et ensuite on sait pas ce
qui fait quand même beaucoup mieux avoir
passé du bullet tout ça peut te rendre
mêmes caisses et 6 intercepté dans 26
qui font une publicité le truc tellement
tout tempo quoi mais ça aurait peut-être
pu jouer à tour un moment
malheureusement ces beaux oiseaux aussi
tempo que sa part et je sais c'est que
quand tu joues tout tempo comme ça tu
mets la pression femmes moins un ace qui
se passe quoi incroyable quoi mais étant
de ruiz mais doris peut-être mais non il
y avait des fonds au stade je pense je
suis une sorte de rhuys bizarre là je
pense que guy ils ont un problème de
connexion
ils appellent leurs vitres suffrages en
ce qu'il boit le calice jusqu'à la lie
quoi est il fait une anti russe ce
portique bull et android
il est là que je pensais
malchance les mecs de tissi felisha de
risques et il fallait bien les bisous ce
qui lui avait tant de récompenser les
manifs ou mamediarov coiffe numéro 3
mondial s'est mis à me tendre risque
enfin si un joueur de toute l'histoire
ouais il a compris quoi ils n'auraient
officielle des échecs
ouais ça avec croyait il est encore
mieux il peut revenir il peut égaliser
la romieu je cherchais le reflet donc il
faut tenir les cases comme on n'a pas
trop fait la méthode d'anti jeu c'est
pas si grave pour moi ça se tient
ouais en plus ses pions vous voulez
surtout sa ferme ou froids f-7124 nom
[Musique]
soit connu martina kg joker souffre
aujourd'hui c'est vrai je pense qu'elle
fait nul en force sur tout tout bouffer
du curé résident en zone rurale ok mais
c'est à dire qu'ils gagnent pas s'avère
que mam est de nouveau les blancs et à 7
minutes fab five c'est bouillant ce
match a besoin de bras qui a proposé les
aigris qui a refusé
l'ibérique en train de se dire faut
quelques jours un peu la montre ne veut
pas que guy à n'accepter aucune de l'onu
il avait proposé fin mai son patron des
répétitions paris live un peu joué là je
pense améliorer en fait la partie pour
durer sept minutes ça répète il a pas
fait
non mais faut en revanche femme un truc
important à dire c'est qu'il est
abandonné et tout dire il n'a pas fait
il n'a pas fait d'antijeu quoi remettre
de ce choc n'a pas du tout fait ce que
twitter la partie d'abandonner duras et
25 sont durs et que jusqu'au mater tous
n'en faut pas je pense qu souligné ça
quand même très sportif guiry même s'il
est un peu dans le dur ou quoi il n'a
pas à ça joue vraiment aux échecs ce
soir à femmes
mamede tellement au fond du sac
enfin n'importe quoi et les îles à la
salle et grands joueurs aussi avant les
feux de de trucs à l'autre
il y avait six minutes m'avait capture
pas le droit de perdre mais une lune de
l'éliminent par un fab nom est toujours
à un point
sinon l'a4 tout ça comment les nerfs
solides
quelle fin de match
et bientôt on va se faire le petit aussi
mv elle n'a qu'à ça va être là ces
quarts de finale démarre cette forme
formidable ce match mais on espère
qu'ils vont pour le signe indien coi il
a collé à naka enfin sur internet mais
n'a cassé jamais eu de membres est il
faut commencer à lui coller mais bon non
mais qu'est ce démon chaque fois je
jouais à la fin j malta playoffs
on n'a qu'à cette année il rêvait le
battre je boite artistes double tournant
face à pascal point de vue mais il a
raté
y a pas eu que 10 des cinq échappés
cette fois c'est juste qu'en france et 3
est tombé à mon âge et de mes deux
jambes et deux quand même
allez dur cela pour ramer mais bon il
sera pas éliminé si la mer il lui reste
normalement encore deux parties ok
d'amendé direct voyager raison de
participants il faut rester dehors parce
qu'il ya quatre minutes samedi leurs
efforts pour gagner ce lot c'est fini
c'est ça ouais essart match pas allez
c'est parti vite corrigé de gagner
ils vont avoir apprécié guy riffé fait
le truc de sacha en fait ce sont ces cas
là c'est dommage car inquiets par la
précédente gay ouais ça dure à gagner ça
whatever 06 le saint sava dur femmes
on loue des recettes qui partent pour
les cages à prendre ouais les eaux
troubles mais c'est pas très bon ça
c'est autre et trouve le saf à vin même
très sale dans l'eau du gange
bon écoute si la naksa c
assez extraordinaire faisable après un
feu âmes est bon plus gris prendre les
choses au sérieux ils sont avec son
voyage peut attraper dans le coin la
green est bien réelle
bien joué de la part de guéri à temps il
ya maintenant oui j'ai espéré quoi on va
peut-être que nulle quoi rien son chrono
c'est ce que je me tourne vers nulle ni
veut faire ils doivent aider si peu à
paris match
je crois qu'il acquerra 6,50
mam et qui doit tenter de gagner très
vite sa page 5
pour sa part est quasi-impossible fable
de gagner les deux mais maintenant ça
donne souvent des hommes non il a mis
trente là pour la gagne
tout est beau c'est pas la bonne
position 1 c'est parti pour une nuit de
36 pièces sur l'échiquier et pourra s'en
vouloir un des deux trois finales bêtes
là il a perdu à un moment donné dans le
match mettant pas ça tu vas passer sur
le tennis simic et les gens rentrent sur
le court mon échauffement peu d'autres
façons elles restent plus longtemps à
l'instar pessoa presse montre entre
fasse une transe quand même dommage de
pas su le match jusqu'au bout du bout la
sfic 54 secondes dans le grand maître
officiel j'ai le chronomètre officiel
fab
malheureusement ma may cry 52 secondes
waimes après guéri comme il n'a pas fait
ça je me dis si tu finis pas glorieux et
ses amis même esquissé grille est
vraiment de temps quoi peut-être qu'il
ya pas le trouve sous les yeux je sais
pas moi mais ben écoute ça c'est quand
même mérité 1
mérité femmes cette victoire de geri
quand même sur l'ensemble du match mais
après il ya un passage tout d'un coup
ces prix là la tornade quoi il aurait pu
se prendre la tornade dès le début ça
m'amuse bien sûr le niveau pour ehsayer
fab
ça y est écoulé le temps est écoulé et
basse ajoute que la dernière pour voir
si ça finit mais s'ils meurent un point
ce sera vraiment cruel pour mam est
quand même aussi un il fera se rappeler
des occasions manquées pendant l'année
en y pensant leur tv même pas dire à un
moment il a fait h3c toutes ces
conneries
le bk que le pire de la pièce en vain
coût 22 ans il était plein de trucs
incroyables
il a juste très mal joué après il a
rejoué bien mais il est une phase
horrible dès qu'il a senti nos critiques
on me disait tu peux tu peux ne pas être
champion du monde en jouant aussi mal et
tous deux se souvenir aussi de sacrés
chaque année
mais bon comme quoi ces matches ce pitch
assez marrant parce que ça tellement été
passé réellement machin pas de surprise
les matchs qui se retournait pas et tout
est là ça fait 2 2 soirs d'affilée ou
wii puis même genre l'habitude des
matches où il y avait un écart au début
enfin il jamais personne qui a fait nous
même menacé de faire des vrais remonte à
la en fait ouais gros j'arrivais à une
autre partie légalise us et puis c'est
pas ce qui se passe après va sûrement
pas mon gars - angle il va mourir à
moins et mieux pour nous on aura moins
d'argent et moins jeunes ne savent pas
combien de temps il reste fait du coma
mais c'est de la gagner que s'en fout
pranger 5e
je crois que le maté quel génie vraie
séance on qui presse avec les bleus en
fait mais il ya encore 50 secondes le
fait enfin ils seront tous implorant
c'est génial je préfère nul quoi ça
intéresse pas well as à dire sur autre
chose et h2i mieux aux besoins de nos
matches ouais c'est vraiment beau match
phare au final bien bien libre et que
les nazis
ouais ouais franchement franchement
franchement beau match ça a été très
très agréable à suivre fab avec avec ce
petit frisson donc les prochains matches
on n'a pas encore les dates officielles
mais ce qui est sûr fabre c'est qu'il y
aura le nak amv elle qui sera vraiment
le match quoi oui cela fige
après bon alors à rognan guiry qui va
être très intéressant ouais non deux
plus belles affiches bon français elle
est même à rognan guiry sympa aussi
oui bien sûr bien sûr très sympa très
sympa marronniers andy rihs bah écoutez
vous a plu great soul donnera aussi très
sympa fab web mail à web et l'écriture
occupé mais bon on va écouter les
tontons merci à tous d'avoir suivi
c'était vraiment une super soirée ont
été notre compagnie et aaron et vous sur
la chaîne du tri à partir de mardi pour
gary comment vivra de nouveau ouais
ouais ouais
et puis vint toujours la chaîne
chaîne youtube les vidéos les like et
tout peut tout ce à quoi vous connaissez
à bientôt les continuelles enel pour la
poutre